Rồi các bạn hôm qua chúng ta đã bắt đầu
chúng ta làm quen với một vài những cái
thuật toán cơ bản và những thuật toán
đầu tiên trong machining đúng không? Đi
qua lại một tí nhá. Chúng ta còn nói về
nhất là linear reaction đúng không?
Linear reaction là cái chất toán có thể
coi là cơ bản nhất. Được chưa? Linear
reaction là toán dành cho bài toán rehi
chúng ta chỉ dùng những cái hàm bậc một
để chúng ta có thể mô phỏng mối quan hệ
giữa đầu vào với cả đầu ra. Được chưa?
Chúng ta sẽ có cả polynomial regression
đúng không? Nếu mà linear reaction là
tập toán bậc 1 thì polynomial reaction
là tập toán bậc n đúng không? Bậc n. Thế
thì đây đều là hai tập toán dành cho bài
toán request.
Tiếp theo chúng ta có một thuật toán
cũng có chữ regression nhưng nó là thuật
toán dành cho bài toán classification đó
là logistic reaction. Logistic reaction
là phiên bản mở rộng của linear
reaction. nó thay đổi một chút để nó có
thể áp dụng được cho bài toán phân loại.
Được chưa? Chúng ta sau chúng ta tìm
hiểu về à knife bias được chưa? Sau
chúng ta nói về
decent tre nói về decentry đây. Chúng ta
sẽ kết thúc ở decent tree. Deci treết
định đây là một tập toán rất là phổ biến
trong machin được xây dựng dựa trên cấu
trúc dạng cây. Bạn nào mà các bạn học
công nghệ đông tin, các bạn học cái môn
cấu trúc dựa và và giải thuật thì các
bạn không còn xa lạ gì về cái cấu trúc
dạng cây này nữa đúng không? Chúng ta
xây dựng một cái cây để làm sao sau này
khi mà chúng ta muốn đưa ra một cái dự
đoán chúng ta sẽ đi dọc theo cái thân
của cái cây này để chúng ta xem là cái
quyết định nó là cái gì đúng không? Hôm
qua chúng ta có dừng lại cái đạn chúng
ta nói về việc là bây giờ cái bộ rượu
chúng ta nó có nhiều feature như thế
này. Nó có bốn feature này thì làm sao
tôi có thể quyết định là tôi sẽ tôi sẽ
dựa vào feature nào để tôi có thể đưa ra
dự đoán bây giờ đúng không? Tôi dựa vào
age, tôi dựa vào income, tôi dựa vào
student hay là tôi dựa vào credit đúng
không? Thì hôm qua mình có nhắc lại mình
có chốt ở cái việc là gì là chúng ta sẽ
muốn chọn cái feature nào mà để khi nó
đưa ra những cái dự đoán này nó càng
lệch thì càng tốt. Lệch là gì? Ví dụ các
bạn nhá. 40 này lệch này đúng không?
Chúng ta muốn nó càng lệch như thế này
thì nó càng tốt. 40 này hoặc là 31 này
hoặc là 61 đúng không? Càng lệch thì
càng tốt.
Và có rất nhiều các cái tiêu chí để có
thể dựa vào để chúng ta có thể tính được
cái độ lệch này. Và một trong số cái
tiêu chí phổ biến nhất thì người ta gọi
là Gini Index. Ngoài cái gid này con có
một vài cái tiêu chí khác nữa nhưng mà
gidin là cái phổ biến và hay được sử
dụng rộng rãi nhất. Đấy giờ vào gidin
chúng ta có cái công thức như này đúng
không? Hôm qua chúng ta có tính thử rồi
đây đúng không? Ví dụ chúng ta muốn tính
cái chỉ số gini hay là gini index của
cái này thì chúng ta muốn tính được của
cái
của cái của cái feature này chúng ta
phải tính được từng cái nhánh con một
đúng không? Từng cái nhánh con chúng ta
sẽ dùng công thức này. Được chưa? Cái
công thức đây đúng không? 1 trừ đi tổng
sigma của y chạy từ 1 cho đến c của p
bình phương. C là số lượng class. Trong
trường hợp này chúng ta có hai class
thôi. Đúng I chạy từ 1 cho đến 2 đúng
không? Cái nhánh đầu tiên này ví dụ cái
yes nó bằng 2. No bằng 3 này thì v1 thì
bằng 2 chia 5 là bằng 0,4. V2 là bằng 3
chia 5 là bằng 0,6. Ini nó bằng 1 trừ đi
0,4 bình cộng với 0,6 bình thì bằng
0,48. Được chưa? Đây là cái đây là cái
ví dụ để cách ta tính được cái gini
index của cái nhánh
này đúng không? Tương tự như vậy với hai
cái nhánh kia chúng ta cũng sẽ làm tương
tự như thế.
Và các bạn thấy này cái chỉ số gin index
rồi cái chỉ số này nó sẽ có giá trị từ 0
cho đến 0,5. Càng gần 0 thì càng tốt,
càng gần 0,5 thì càng tồi. Được chưa?
Cần 0 là như này đây. Như này là 0 này.
Lệch hết cái một bên thì 0 này. Còn nếu
mà nó đều nhau thì nó sẽ là 0,5 được
không? Càng gần 0 thì càng tốt, càng gần
0,5 thì càng tồi. Được chưa? Thế đây là
cách bạn tính điểm cho từng cái nhánh
một. Thế thì bây giờ khi mà tôi muốn
tính điểm cho cái cả cái này của cái
feature này tôi sẽ tính trung bình có
trọng số của ba ông kia thôi. Đây trọng
số này đúng không? 0 0,48 nhân 5/14 này
cộng với 0 nhân 4,14 này cộng với 0,48
nhân 5/14 này cộng lại bằng 0,343. Được
chưa? Thì đây là cái gin index của cả
cái feature này. Được chưa?
Và chúng ta cũng sẽ làm tương tự như vậy
với những cái feature còn lại. Thì tóm
lại là bây giờ ông nào có cái chỉ số này
nó thấp nhất thì ông đấy sẽ được chọn
cái nút gốc. Sau đó người ta sẽ tiếp tục
người ta sẽ phát triển để người ta có
thể mở rộng tiếp cái cây. Được chưa? Thế
thì [khịt mũi] DC là một toán đơn giản,
thường cái performance nó sẽ không quá
cao nhưng mà nó được cái là nó dễ xây
dựng và nó rất là dễ giải thích. Dễ giải
thích có nghĩa là gì? Có nghĩa là sau
này chúng ta rất là dễ chúng ta có thể
giải thích là vì sao tôi lại đưa ra
quyết định như vậy đúng không? Ví dụ bây
giờ có một người mà người ta bị từ chối
chẳng hạn đúng không? Người ta bị từ
chối không nhận job này. Mô hình nó gợi
ý là không nên nhận cái người này thì
mình có thể giải thích là vì sao lại như
vậy đúng không? Tại vì là sao? Người ta
người ta có bằng đại học này đúng không?
có bằng đại học này à
bằng không phải bằng giỏi đúng không và
cũng không có I luôn nên là tôi từ chối
đúng không hoặc là bây giờ tôi nhận ông
này tại vì là ông đấy tuy là không có
băng đại học nhưng mà ông ấy lại có có
kinh nghiệm làm việc rồi thì tôi nhận
ông đấy đúng không? Thì cái đoạn này nó
rất là dễ giải thích, có những toán nó
rất là dễ giải thích và có những tán nó
không dễ giải thích như vậy. Hôm qua
chúng ta đều học những tội toán nó khá
là đơn giản, rất là dễ để giải thích.
Thì hôm nay chúng ta sẽ làm quen với
những tội toán nó phức tạp hơn, nó khai
thác những mối quan hệ phi tuyến nó phức
tạp hơn và nó sẽ khó có thể giải thích
hơn. Được chưa?
Thì hôm qua chú nói về decyent thì DC là
một cái cây đúng không? Deci nó là một
cái cây. Được chưa? Thế thì thế thì
trong a trong machining ấy nó có một cái
thuật toán để nó có thể nó sử dụng tập
hợp của nhiều cái cây lại để giúp cho
tôi tăng cái độ chính xác của mô hình.
Thì cái thật toàn như vậy ta gọi là
random forest. Được chưa? DC là một cây,
random forest là nhiều cây. Các bạn
tưởng tượng decent nó là một người,
random forest là giống như nhiều người.
Các bạn ấy trong cuộc trong cuộc sống
thực tế đúng không? Thì khi mà chúng ta
muốn đưa ra một cái quyết định quan
trọng gì đấy đúng không? Thường người ta
sẽ không ai người ta dựa vào quyết định
của một người cả mà thường người ta sẽ
phải có một cái tập hợp, một cái hội
đồng người ta bỏ phiếu đúng không? Một
cái tập thể bỏ phiếu thì đấy chính là
cái hình ảnh phản chiếu của Random
Forest đúng không? Khi mà tôi đưa ra một
quyết định, tôi sẽ không chỉ dựa vào một
mô hình, một cái cây mà tôi sẽ dựa vào
nhiều cái cây như vậy. Đấy là cái ý
tưởng của random Forest.
Thì cái từ toán random fres này ấ các
bạn chú ý này, cái random fres này ấ nó
sẽ có cái đặc điểm này. Tức là bây giờ
ấy nó cũng giống như kiểu là tôi muốn
làm sao tôi tập hợp sức mạnh của nhiều
người để khi mà mỗi một khi tôi đưa cần
đưa ra một cái quyết định gì đấy thì tôi
sẽ đưa quyết định một cách chính xác
hơn, đúng không? Tránh việc là tôi dựa
vào mỗi một cái quyết định của một người
thôi thì người ta người ta có thể bị cảm
tính hoặc là người ta không có giỏi về
cái lĩnh vực đấy đúng không? Đế b tôi
kết hợp sức mạnh của nhiều người.
Thế nhưng bây giờ ấy khi mà tôi muốn xây
dựng cái tội toán đ thì nó có một cái
yêu cầu như thế này là gì? Bây giờ ở đây
thay vì tôi có một cái cây đúng không?
Tôi có ví dụ tôi có 100 cái cây đi
không? Tôi có 100 cây. Thế nhưng mà bây
giờ ấy để tôi đảm bảo là cái việc tôi sử
dụng nhiều cái cây này nó có ý nghĩa thì
tôi phải làm nào? thì tôi phải đảm bảo
là gì? Là 100 cái cây này chúng nó phải
được huấn luyện khác nhau. Huấn luyện
khác nhau đây có nghĩa gì? Có nghĩa là
cái bộ dữ liệu được dùng để huấn luyện
chúng ấy là phải khác nhau chứ còn nếu
bây giờ tôi dùng đúng một cái tập trang
bình thường tôi dùng đúng cái tập trang
tôi dùng huấn luyện decent tre bây giờ
tôi dùng đúng cái tập trấy. Tôi huấn
luyện các cái decent tre trong random
fred ấy đúng không? Nếu tôi dùng chung
một cái bộ dữ liệu như vậy thì tất cả
100 cái cây này đúng không? Nó sẽ đưa ra
quyết định giống y hiệt nhau. Thì lúc
này cái việc mà tôi có 100 cây hay là
1000 cây nó cũng chả có ý nghĩa gì cả.
Tại vì bây giờ nếu mà có nhiều đúng
không? Có nhiều người nhưng mà bây giờ
người nào cũng ra quyết định như vậy thì
nó có ý nghĩa gì đâu đúng không? Thế tôi
phải đảm bảo là gì? Là các cái disent
này sẽ phải được huấn luyện trên các cái
bộ rượu khác nhau đúng không? Thế làm
sao để làm được như vậy thì tôi sẽ đúng
rồi. Một cây là một mô hình chính xác.
Mỗi một cây này trên một cái mô hình con
chính xác là như vậy. Thế thì bây giờ
tôi có một cái tôi sau khi tôi có cái bộ
rượu tôi tôi phân chia thành bộ tr bộ va
bộ test các thứ rồi đúng không? Thì bây
giờ với cái bộ trin đúng không? Bình
thường mọi khi mình dùng bộ trin để mình
huấn luyện decent tre. Nhưng bây giờ
mình không thể dùng cái bộ rượu đấy để
huấn luyện chung cho tất cả những mô
hình này. Tại vì nếu dùng như vậy thì
100 cây này huấn luyện nó nó dự đoán y
hiệt nhau đúng không? Thì bây giờ tôi
phải dựa một cái kỹ thuật gọi là gọi là
boot shopping. Cái kỹ thuật boot
shopping này là cái kỹ thuật được sử
dụng để tôi có thể làm gì? Để tôi có thể
tôi sẽ tạo ra các cái bộ dữ liệu con để
dùng để huấn luyện các cái cây của chúng
ta.
Boot shopping tên như thế này nhưng
trong thực tế các bạn hiểu một cách đơn
giản nó chính là kỹ thuật lấy mẫu có
hoàn lại. Ngày xưa các bạn học phổ thông
các bạn học lớp 11 các bạn học về sắp
suất rồi đúng không? Thế nào gọi là lấy
mẫu có hẳn lại? Lấy mẫu có hẳn lại tôi.
Lấy ra từ thì mẫu tôi xem là cái gì xong
tôi đặt lại chỗ cũ để tôi lấy được chưa?
Thế [khịt mũi] bây giờ từ cái tập gốc
này ví dụ cái tập gốc của ta, cái tập
training của ta nó có các cái phần tử là
A B C D EF đúng không? Thì bây giờ tôi
sẽ như mình vừa nói tôi sẽ không dùng
toàn bộ cái tập này để tôi huấn luyện mô
hình. Đây là tập trên nhá. Tức là đã
phân chia trên trên va test riêng rồi
nhá. Đây là tập trang được chưa? Thì bây
giờ tôi sẽ phải làm sao? Tôi sẽ vẻ. Ví
dụ tôi bây gi tôi có bốn cái cây đi được
chưa? Tôi có bốn cái cây thì bây giờ bốn
cây này tôi sẽ không dùng tôi sẽ không
dùng chung cái tập trơ này tôi huấn
luyện mà tôi sẽ phải lấy ra cái tập con.
Mỗi khi lấy mỗi khi lấy cái tập con này
tôi sẽ dùng kỹ thuật boot shopping lấy
mẫu có hoàn lại đúng không? Lấy mẫu có
hoàn lại nó sẽ có khả năng là gì? Là một
sample sẽ lấy nhiều lần đúng không? Tại
vì tôi hoàn lại mà hoàn lại thì có khả
năng là lần tới tôi lại lấy đúng cái
phần tử đấy nữa được chưa? Thế thì dựa
vào boot shopping hay là nếu m có còn
lại như này thì tôi sẽ lấy ra được bốn
cái bộ con như này được chưa? Bốn cái
tập con như này. Và sau đó thì với mỗi
một cái tập con này tôi sẽ dùng để tôi
lệ những cây khác nhau đúng không? Tôi
có bốn cái cây tôi sẽ dùng bốn tập con
này để huấn luyện bốn cái cây đó. Được
chưa? Đấy người ta gọi là boot shopping.
Boot shopping làm như này để làm gì? Làm
như này để đảm bảo các cái cây của chúng
ta được huấn luyện khác nhau. Đưa huấn
luyện khác nhau nó sẽ đưa những cái dự
đoán đa dạng khác nhau thì lúc này cái
việc tôi dùng nhiều cây nó mới có ý
nghĩa đúng không? Thế đây ví dụ đây. Đây
là cái mô phỏng đây đúng không? T gì
chúng ta có tập trang được chưa? Từ mỗi
cái tập chân này tôi sẽ lấy tôi sẽ dùng
cái đật boot shopping để tôi có thể lấy
ra những cái tập con. Thông thường cái
tập con này nó sẽ có khoảng kích thước
khoảng 70% so với tập gốc ban đầu. Ví dụ
ban đầu các bạn có 1000 sample thì mỗi
một cái tập con này nó sẽ khoảng 700
được chưa? Nó sẽ vừa ít hơn.
Tập con 4 B thì thì mình vừa nói rồi.
Lấy mẫu có hoàn lại đấy đúng không? Thế
mới gọi là lấy mẫu có hoàn lại đúng
không? Lấy mẫu có hoàn lại thì sẽ có khả
năng là gì? Là một sle được lấy nhiều
lần đúng không? Thế người ta mới gọi lấy
mẫu cón lại. Thế còn lấy mẫu không còn
lại tức là gì? Lấy xong là tôi sẽ để
trong cái tập của tôi luôn. Lấy xong tôi
lấy xong là tôi để đấy luôn đúng không?
Thì lấy mẫu không còn lại thì sẽ đảm bảo
là mỗi lần lấy nó sẽ lấy những phần tử
khác nhau đúng không? Còn lấy mẫu có
hoàn lại thì sẽ có khả năng là một phần
tử sẽ lấy nhiều lần đúng không?
Rồi đúng không? Bootspping là lấy mẫu có
hoàn lại nên sẽ có khả năng là một
sample sẽ được lấy đi lấy lại nhiều lần.
Được chưa?
Đấy. Đấy gọi là boot shopping. Và đây
chúng ta có bao nhiêu cái cây chúng ta
sẽ phải boot shopping chúng ta sẽ phải
lấy ra từng mấy tập con. Được chưa? Mỗi
tập con nó sẽ khoảng 70% số lượng sample
của tập gốc ban đầu. Đấy. Xong người ta
sẽ dùng tập con này người ta huấn luyện
những cây khác nhau. Thì bây giờ ấy
những cây này ấ được huấn luyện với
những cái tập con khác nhau nên chúng ta
cũng sẽ học theo những hướng khác nhau.
Được chưa? Giống kiểu bây giờ các bạn có
10 bộ đề bây các bạn dùng để huấn luyện
à bạn để dạy học cho 50 học sinh thì bây
giờ mỗi học sinh các bạn chỉ lấy bảy bộ
đề thôi đúng không? Thì mỗi ông nó sẽ
học một kiểu khác nhau. Đấy chưa? Và để
tăng cho cái tính đa dạng này nữa thì
khi người ta huấn luyện những cái cây
này ấ ở mỗi một cái note chúng ta phải
quyết định xem là chọn cái ông nào là
cái decision note ấy. Đây này nhá. Các
bạn nhớ buổi buổi trước cho nói đúng
không? Tức là chúng ta sẽ phải có cái
bước chúng ta quyết định xem là chúng ta
sẽ chọn cái nốt nào ở từng cái decision
note đúng không? Thì bây giờ ấy ở mỗi
một cái bước này ấy để cho nó đa dạng
hơn thì bây giờ giả sử các bạn có tổng
cộng các bạn có 10 feature đi đúng
không? Các bạn có 10 feature thì bây giờ
mỗi một cây ấ mỗi một khi chúng ta quyết
định số bạn chọn decision note ấy chúng
ta sẽ chỉ chọn một trong số ví dụ một
trong số bảy feature thôi. Tức là gì?
Chúng ta sẽ không cho phép là chọn toàn
bộ feature, chúng ta chỉ cho chọn một
cái tập con thôi, đúng không? Tôi lấy
70% dữ liệu và mỗi một cái note này, tôi
chẽ chỉ lấy 70% số lượng feature thôi để
tôi tăng cái tính đa dạng của những cây
của tôi đúng không? Tôi tăng cái tính đa
dạng cái cây này. Tôi làm sao cho cái
cây tôi nó càng đa dạng thì càng tốt.
Tại vì đa dạng như vậy thì cái việc các
bạn lấy nhiều cây nó mới có ý nghĩa đúng
không? Chứ còn nếu mà nó chúng nó cứ xêm
xêm nhau thì nhiều cây với một cây nó
chả khác gì nhau cả. Thì sau đó tôi sẽ
tổng kết lại để tôi ra được cái
prediction của tôi. Được chưa? Tôi tổng
kết để tôi ra được cái prediction.
Nhưng mà cái tổng kết này tổng kết như
thế nào nó còn phụ thuộc vào bài toán.
Được chưa? Tổng kết như thế nào nó còn
phụ thuộc vào bài toán. Nếu đây là bài
toán classification được chưa? Nếu đây
là bài toán phân loại được chưa? Nếu nó
là bài toán phân loại thì cái prition
này sẽ được tổng kết theo kiểu là gì?
Với bài toán phân loại người ta tổng kết
như nào các bạn?
>> Đa số á.
>> Đúng rồi. Nếu là phân loại thì nó sẽ là
đa số đánh mạnh thiểu số. Được chưa? Cái
class nào mà nhiều cây chọn nhất thì đấy
là cái dự đoán của tôi. Thế còn nếu mà
nó nó là bài toán rewestion tôi tính
trung bình thôi. Ví dụ nó mình dự án giá
nhà 100 cây dự án 100 cái giá tôi sẽ
cộng chia trung bình lại là xong. Được
chưa? Đấy là cách để nó tổng kết lại như
này được chưa? Thì đầm FR nó là thuật
toán mà nó sẽ giúp cải thiện cái
performance so với các cái decision tre
lẻ đúng không? Giống như kiểu trong xã
hội này thôi đúng không? Bây giờ các bạn
chỉ hỏi ý kiến một người thôi thì có thể
nó sẽ có những cái sai số. Thì bây giỏi
ý kiến của nhiều người rồi tôi tổng kết
lại thì tôi sẽ giảm cái khả năng tôi gặp
sai lệch đi. Nhớ chưa? Thì đấy là ý
tưởng của random forest được chưa?
Decision tre nếu mình nhớ không là
feature nó là cái
>> dạ
>> cái ví dụ lần trước thầy nói 70% feature
nó là cái gì vậy?
>> Feature đây ạ. Đây feature đây. Income
is student tương thầy nói là 70% có
nghĩa là gì? Trong cái ví dụ này có thể
là gì?
>> Ví dụ th
>> đấy thầy nói cái ví dụ là lấy 70%
feature thì có thể là cái gì? Tức là nếu
việc mình có 10 feature, nếu mình có đây
là mình có bốn feature đây. Trong trờ ví
dụ mình có 10 feature chẳng hạn thì mỗi
khi mà tôi phải quyết định xem là cái
feature nào sẽ được dùng ở cái decision
note này. Tôi chỉ chọn một trong số 70%
số lượng feature thôi. Tôi chỉ lấy 70%
tức là tôi tổng tôi có 10 tôi cũng chỉ
chọn một trong bảy cái thôi.
Để tôi
>> thế nếu như có cái feature nó phụ thuộc
vào nhau như thế này thì như thế nào? Ví
dụ như là mình không thể nào mà mình lấy
cái feature là có I nhưng mà mình không
qua được cái bằng giỏi trước. Không
không bằng giỏi I là hai cái nó chả liên
quan đến nhau. Bằng giỏi là lúc mình học
ở trên trường đại học còn I là lúc mình
đi thi ở ngoài hai cái nó không liên
quan đến nhau.
>> Ok. Thế th đây là một cái ví dụ của một
cái model là để nó link lại với nhau.
Thì còn có những cái feature khác thì nó
có thể là không mỗi một cái feature nó
in gọi là gì? Independent là gì? Là độc
lập với nhau. Độc lập. Ừ.
>> Tức là
>> ok. Tức là ví dụ ở đây mình không phải
không phải mình có bốn feature, mình có
10 feature. Bình thường với decision
free mỗi khi mình quyết định xem là ở
một cái nốt ví dụ mình ở cái nốt chỗ này
mình sẽ chọn cái feature nào là mình sẽ
chọn một trong số 10 feature. Đấy là đối
với decision tre.
Nhưng mà đối với Red để cho tăng cái
tính đa dạng thì ở đây mỗi một cái chỗ
này khi mà tôi phải quyết định xem là
tôi chọn cái feature nào, tôi sẽ không
chọn 110 mà tôi chỉ chọn một trong 7
thôi.
Chọn một trong 7 thôi. Hôm này tôi chỉ
chọn một trong 7 thôi. B7 một trong 7 và
một trong để tôi làm tăng cái sự đa
dạng. Tôi làm tăng cái sự khác biệt giữa
các cái cây với nhau đi. Tại vì bây giờ
nếu cây nào cũng được chọn full 10
feature cả thì nó sẽ rất là dễ tương
đồng với nhau.
>> Ừ. Đấy, ví dụ mình có tổng cộng 10 thì
70% là bảy feature thôi. Thì mỗi một khi
mình chọn cái nốt này tôi chỉ chọn một
trong 7 thôi. Tôi cứ lấy ra bảy cái
feature ngẫu nhiên tôi cho nó chọn chỉ
trong này thôi, không được chọn full
toàn bộ.
>> Nhưng mà cái decision 3 nó cũng có cái
phụ thuộc lẫn nhau phải không? Như cái
ví dụ này chẳng hạn
>> không phụ thuộc nhau là không quan
trọng. Nó đây mình đây là một cái ví dụ
nó coi như là feature này nó không phụ
thuộc nhau không quan trọng. phụ thuộc
hay không phụ thuộc thì tôi cũng sẽ được
tôi thì tôi cũng thì tôi cũng cái này
cái này không không phải là phải có cái
bằng đại học thì mới có bằng giò các thứ
này không phải như vậy đây là một cái ví
dụ thôi ví dụ như trong cái ví dụ này
chẳng hạn đây bố này nó tho là nó có
liên quan đến nhau đâu nó hoàn toàn độc
lập về nhau không phải không phải không
phải đ không phải độc lập về mặt ý nghĩa
tức là không phải là tôi phải chọn ông
này rồi tôi mới đưa chọn ông kia chọn
một cách bình đẳng vai trò của chúng là
bình đẳng với nhau đấy
>> thế nhưng mà nếu như mà Ừ. Có bao giờ có
những cái feature mà nó có phụ thuộc vào
nhau thì làm như thế nào?
>> Ví dụ như thế nào ạ?
>> Ví dụ như là
à so sánh nhà ở thành phố thì thành vì
phải có ở thành phố thì nói nào nhở?
Ờ
tự nhiên vào ví dụ chương dậ đây đây
cũng là một ví dụ có phải không? cái cái
cái đ cái trên màn hình như mà tức chung
thế này mỗi một cái simple mỗi một cái
simple ví dụ đây có bốn feature thì mỗi
một cái simple nó sẽ phải có dữ liệu cho
cả bốn feature thế nên mình dùng cái nào
cũng được mình dùng cái nào cũng được
ông nào cũng có age ông nào cũng có
income ông nào cũng có cái trạng thái là
có phải sinh viên hay không và ông nào
cái rating nên là chọn ông nào cũng được
không nhất thiết là phải ông này rồi thì
đến ông kia đây là một cái ví dụ minh
họa là tôi đi cá nhánh như này đ nhưng
mà trong thực tế thì tại vì là dù Dù có
độc lập hay phụ thuộc vào nhau ấy thì
mỗi một sample nó đều có đủ từ này thông
tin và khi nó có đủ thông tin nó không
bị khuyết đúng không? Vụ diệu mình là bộ
diện nó không bị khuyết và khi không bị
khuyết thì tôi chọn cái nào cũng được.
>> Đó mỗi một cái chỗ này nó nó có bị
khuyết cái gì đâu. Nó không bị khuyết
thì chọn cái nào mà chả được đúng không?
>> Ừ.
>> Đó.
>> Ok.
>> Rồi các bạn nhớ nhá. Để tôi muốn làm
tăng cái độ đa dạng cái tăng cái
variance giữa các cái cây ý thì như mình
nói thứ nhất là dùng boot shopping để
tôi đảm bảo gì? thì tôi đảm bảo là mỗi
một cây này sẽ được huấn luyện trên
những cái bộ rượu con khác nhau. Và cái
thứ hai nữa là gì? Là khi mà tôi xây
dựng những cái cây này đúng không? Tôi
chọn cái decion note thì mỗi khi mà tôi
chọn một cái feature ở từng cái decion
note ấy, tôi sẽ không cho nó phép tôi
không cho phép nó chọn toàn bộ feature
mà tôi chỉ cho một trong số một cái tập
con của các cái feature thôi đúng không?
Thường là 70% tôi tăng cái sự đa dạng,
tăng cái sự khác biệt giữa các cái cây
này với nhau. Được chưa? Càng đa dạng
thì cái thì cái việc sử dụng nhiều cây
nó càng có ý nghĩa đúng không? Chứ còn
bây giờ 100 cây mà nó dư nó xêm xêm nhau
thì việc có nhiều cây nó cũng chả có ý
nghĩa gì cả. Được chưa?
>> Anh ơi cho em hỏi chút vô
>> ừ
>> cái chỗ boot strapping ấy là khi mà anh
cắt dữ liệu có hoàn trải này là anh cắt
theo dòng à đúng không anh? Cắt 70% dữ
liệu đấy là anh cắt theo dòng đúng không
ạ?
>> Một s là một dòng. Đúng rồi các bạn. Đây
là chúng cắt theo dòng xong là từ cái bộ
dữ liệu đã cắt anh chuên cho đi các cái
cây ở trong random forest ấy thì anh sẽ
lấy mỗi nốt là chỉ thuộc tầm các tập hợp
con số lượng feature ở trong đấy thôi
đúng không?
Tức là cái mỗi cái mỗi cái tập dữ liệu
con này nó vẫn đủ feature
>> nhưng mà khi mà trên cho cái cây ấy thì
anh sẽ không chọn hết feature cho các
notốe.
>> Đúng rồi. Khi mà trên cho cái cây nhá ở
mỗi một nốt đúng không? Bình thường giả
sử tổng cộng có 10 feature đi đúng
không? Thì bây giờ ấy khi mà tôi chọn
mỗi một cái nốt này cho từng cây ấ tôi
chỉ chọn một trong bảy feature thôi. Cứ
mỗi một cái nốt mỗi một cái nốt này khi
tôi phải quyết định tôi sẽ lấy ra một
cái ngẫu nhiên bảy feature và tôi sẽ chỉ
có phép nó chọn một trong số bảy feature
đấy thôi. Đấy.
>> Vâng. Vâng. Em hiểu rồi. Tức là
bootsting nó là cắt một lần là cắt theo
dòng. Còn cái trên cho cây thì anh sẽ
cắt theo cột.
>> Đúng rồi. Bạn có thể hiểu [tiếng cười]
>> là cắt theo cột.
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Vâng.
>> Feature là cột còn sample thì là hàng
đúng không?
>> Vâng. 70% lúc mà tôi lấy boot shopping
là tôi lấy thọp hàng đúng không? Ví dụ
bộ rượu tôi là bộ rượu đặc bảng đúng
không? Tôi có 10 feature, tôi có 1000
cột à tôi có 1000 hàng đúng không? 1000
hàng là 1000 sample, ví dụ là 1000 người
chẳng hạn thì từng cái cây con tôi sẽ
chỉ có lệ với một cái bộ con 700 người
thôi.
Khi triển khai bing trên máy tính thì
mình chuyển như nào? Tay cũng được, thư
viện cũng được, chả thiếu gì cả. Các bạn
dùng Python, các bạn dùng tay thì cũng
ok mà dùng thu viện cũng ok, khó gì đâu.
Đây chỉ đây chỉ là phép lấy mẫu thôi mà.
Lấy mẫu các bạn dùng hàm random là được
ngay đúng không? Có gì đâu?
Dùng tay cũng ok, dùng thư viện cũng ok.
Được chưa? Đopping đơn giản lấy mẫu có
khoản lại. Ngày xưa họ phong các bạn học
rồi đúng không? Nó có hai kiểu lấy mẫu.
Một là lấy mẫu không quản lại, lấy xong
là tôi giữ luôn. Còn hai là lấy mẫu có
lại. Tức là lấy xong tôi xem nó là cái
gì tôi để lại ở chỗ cũ xong tôi lại lấy
tiếp. Đúng không? Đây là lấy mẫu có hoàn
lại được chưa?
Rồi tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá. Thế random
forest là một cái ví dụ của một cái
trường phái nó rất là phổ biến trong
machining. Là cái trường phái mà lấy số
lượng để khỏa lấp chất lượng, lấy số
lượng để bù đắp đi cái nhược điểm về
chất lượng. Tại vì sao? Trong machining
ấy có những thực toán mà nó rất là đơn
giản, nó chạy rất là nhanh, nó tiêu tốn
ít tài nguyên nhưng mà thường cái
performance của nó lại không cao. Thì do
đó thì bây giờ để có thể tận dụng được
những cái mô hình này, người ta sẽ cần
phải việc là gì? Là người ta sẽ lấy số
lượng để người ta bù đắp chất lượng. Tức
là gì? Tôi có một mô hình tôi dự án kém
nhưng tôi sẽ tập hợp nhiều mô hình
giống nhau. Giống nhau là giống nhau về
mạch kiến trúc á. Giống nhau về mạch
kiến trúc. Được chưa? Tôi giống nhau ví
dụ là decent tre thì cùng là decent tre.
Tôi sẽ kết hợp nhiều mô hình như vậy để
tôi có thể tôi cải thiện cái performance
so với việc là tôi dùng một mô hình đơn
lẻ. Được chưa? Thì cái trường phái này
trong machining người ta gọi là
learning. Unsemble learning như thế này
được chưa? Unsemble learning. Và random
forest là một cái ví dụ, một cái trường
hợp, một cái loại biến thể phổ biến nhất
của ansle learning. Trong AS Learning
này nó có rất nhiều những cái cách dùng
con. Tức là gì? Ý tưởng của AC learning
là gì? Là tôi sẽ dùng nhiều mô hình yếu
để tôi có thể cải thiện chất lượng so
với việc là tôi dùng một mô hình đơn lẻ.
Nhưng cụ thể kết hợp nó như thế nào nó
sẽ có nhiều kiểu khác nhau. Có cái kiểu
nó kết hợp kiểu song song, có kiểu nó
kết hợp kiểu nối tiếp, có kiểu nó sẽ hợp
kiểu mix với nhau. Thế bây giờ mình sẽ
đi qua từng kiểu một nhá. Nhưng mà nhìn
chung chúng nó đều gọi là answer
learning. Tức là gì? Dùng nhiều mô hình
so để cải thiện chất lượng so với một mô
hình. Run for là cái ví dụ đầu tiên.
Được chưa? Thì các bạn nhìn nhá. Đầu
tiên có một kỹ thuật gọi là backing.
Backing là viết tắt của Bootshop
aggregating. Được chưa? Both shop
upgrading backing thì random fresh chính
là một cái ví dụ của backing. Random
fresh chính là một cái ví dụ của
backing. Tức là gì? Tức là bây giờ thay
vì tôi chỉ sử dụng một mô hình đơn lẻ để
tôi dự đoán thôi thì bây giờ tôi sẽ sử
dụng nhiều mô hình như vậy đúng không?
Ví dụ bây gián
xem cái sle này nó thuộc về class gì
đúng không? Thì bây giờ thay vì tôi chỉ
dùng một mô hình tôi sẽ dùng nhiều mô
hình. Tất nhiên là tôi phải qua quá
trình tôi huấn luyện rồi đúng không? Ví
dụ là RF chính là một ví dụ đấy. Các bạn
huấn luyện xong rồi thì bây giờ có một
cái mới các bạn muốn nó dự đoán thì các
bạn phải cho nó qua tất cả những cái mô
hình này đúng không? Mỗi mô hình con này
sẽ dự đoán ra một cái một cái kết quả gì
đấy đúng không? Ví dụ đây là bài toán
classification thì tổng kết lại tôi sẽ
dùng là đa số đánh mại tiểu số đúng
không? Cái class nào mà nhiều mô hình nó
vot nhất thì đấy là cái dự án của nó.
Thì đấy là cái ý tưởng của backing.
Backing được xây dựng dựa trên việc là
gì? Là tôi tôi sử dụng nhiều cái biến
thể của cùng một mô hình đúng không?
cùng là decentry chẳng qua là tôi huấn
luyện nói với những cái bộ rượu con khác
nhau thôi. Tôi sẽ được nhiều cái
decentry khác nhau nhưng mà về mặt kiến
trúc thì vẫn là decision tre đúng không?
Thế cùng một kiểu kiến trúc nhưng mà là
nhiều biến thể khác nhau. Được chưa? Và
mỗi một cái này nó sẽ được học song song
với nhau. Học song song và tôi sẽ đảm
bảo là gì? Tôi sẽ đảm bảo là mỗi một cái
mô hình con này sẽ học trên những cái bộ
dữ liệu khác nhau. Trên những cái bộ dữ
liệu con khác nhau để tôi tăng cái tính
đa dạng của chúng đúng không? Đây gọi là
backing. Được chưa? Đây là một trong số
những cái trường phái rất là phổ biến
trongble learning là backing. Được chưa?
Back là dùng song song song song đúng
không? Cái mô hình ở đây ví dụ các bạn
có năm mô hình được huấn luyện song song
với nhau đúng không? Ông này không biết
gì đến sự tồn tại của ông kia đúng
không? Một 100 cây hay là 1000 cây này
chúng nó hoàn toàn chúng nó không biết
đến sự tồn tại của những cây kia đúng
không? Chúng nó chỉ biết là gì? Chúng nó
nhận diệu vào đưa dự đoán đầu ra chấm
hết. Được chưa? đấy là backing.
Nếu mà backing người ta hu luyện song
song thì cái kỹ thuật thứ hai gọi là
boosting. Boosting nó lại theo kiểu là
tuần tự. Tuần tự có nghĩa gì? Tức là bây
giờ tôi vẫn có n cái mô hình, tôi vẫn có
100 cái mô hình nhưng bây giờ 100 cái mô
hình này nó sẽ không đổ luyện song song
mà nó sẽ đổ huấn luyện tuần tự. Và trong
cái trường máy boosting này ấy thì tất
cả các cái mô hình này sẽ đều được huấn
luyện với toàn bộ dữ liệu nhá. Chúng ta
sẽ không cần phải boot shopping, chúng
ta không cần phải lấy tập con nữa, không
cần phải lấy mẫu có hoàn lại nữa. Thì
cái ý tưởng của boosting là gì? Ý tưởng
của boosting có nghĩa là
tôi sẽ
đầu tiên tôi sẽ dùng toàn bộ dữ liệu
tôi, toàn bộ dữ liệu bộ tren đấy nhá.
Tôi huấn luyện cho cái mô hình đầu tiên
được chưa? Cái mô hình đầu tiên này nó
sẽ ra những cái dự đoán. Tất nhiên dự
đoán này nó sẽ có dự đoán đúng và dự
đoán sai đúng không? Thế thì bây giờ sau
khi tôi biết là dự đoán nào đúng, dự
đoán nào sai rồi thì bây giờ tôi sẽ tiếp
tục tôi là gì? Tôi sẽ tiếp tục lấy toàn
bộ dữ liệu của tôi, tôi huấn luyện tiếp
cho cái mô hình thứ hai. Thế nhưng với
cái mô hình thứ hai này, tôi sẽ yêu cầu
của nó là gì? Là nó sẽ phải tập trung
nhiều hơn vào những cái sample mà mô
hình thứ nhất nó bị sai. Giống kiểu này,
cái ông đầu tiên là một bài kiểm tra có
10 câu, mỗi câu đều một điểm. Ok. Ông
đầu tiên là 10 câu, mỗi câu đều một
điểm. Thế bây giờ ông đầu tiên làm 10
câu thì sai mất ba câu chẳng hạn. Thì
cái ông thứ hai ấy khi làm bài vẫn là 10
câu này nhưng mà bây giờ ba cái câu bị
sai ấy. Bây giờ điểm sẽ không phải là 1
mà sẽ là 1,5. Được chưa? Kiểu kiểu như
vậy. Tức là mình sẽ bắt là cái mô hình
sau nó sẽ phải focus hơn, nó sẽ phải tập
trung hơn vào cái lỗi sai của những cái
mô hình trước. Được chưa? Và cứ tiếp tục
tiếp tục như vậy đúng không? Cứ càng mô
hình cứ cái mô hình ngay sau thì phải
tập trung vào những cái sai số của ông
đứng ngay trước nó đúng không? Cái ông
số hai sẽ phải tập trung hơn vào những
cái simple mà ông số một sai. Ông số ba
sẽ phải tập trung nhiều hơn vào những
cái ông những cái simple mà ông số hai
sai. Cứ tiếp tục như vậy. Thì đây là
cách người ta sử dụng các cái mô hình
một cách
tuần tự liên tiếp nhau. Đúng rồi là boot
chính là một kiểu boosting đấy. Xboot
trong boosting nó có nhiều kỹ thuật khác
nhau. Ví dụ như là Guardian boosting
hoặc là boost. Thì đấy chính là các cái
độ khác nhau của cái boosting này.
Boosting này giống như kiểu cái xe xe ô
tô thì guardian boosting nó là xe Audi
này. Rồi boot thì nó là boot thật ra nó
là tên của tên tên nó là tên của
framework thì chính ra luôn. Aribut là
tên của framework. Đấy tức là trong
boosting nó có rất nhiều kỹ thuật khác
nhau nhá. Guardian boosting rồi adab
boost đúng không? Thế còn exbost là tên
của framework. là tên của framework đây
này.
Đây exbot đây này. Tên của framework
được chưa? Trong đấy các bạn sẽ có rất
nhiều cái là boosting boosting khác
nhau. Ờ đây này.
Guardian boost đâu rồi? Nó có nhiều lắm
nó có nhiều toán con con ở trong này.
Được chưa? Đấy. Boosting thì là tuần tự
đúng không? Backing thì là song song.
Với backing thì mỗi một cái mô hình con
sẽ được huấn luyện với những bộ dữ liệu
con khác nhau. Còn với boosting thì tất
cả các cái mô hình con đều được huấn
luyện với cùng cái bộ dữ liệu. Nó chỉ
khác là gì? Là ống sau focus hơn và
những sample và ông trước bị sai. Được
chưa?
Đấy là boosting được chưa? Đây là hai
trường phái đúng không? Trong assing
chúng ta có backing này, chúng
[hắng giọng] ta có boosting này. Được
chưa? Với cả backing và boosting nó đều
có một cái đặc điểm chung là gì? là các
cái mô hình con này về mặt bản chất là
chúng cùng một kiến trúc, cùng là
decision tre hoặc là cùng là một cái mô
hình A BC gì đấy. Được chưa? Tất cả các
mô hình con này đều cùng một kiến trúc.
Thì cái loại tiếp theo, cái loại tiếp
theo là gì? là stacking.
Với stacking ấ thì cái ý tưởng như này.
Cái ý tưởng của stacking tức là bây giờ
tôi
ý tưởng của ý tưởng của stacking ấy là
bây giờ tôi vẫn dùng nhiều mô hình nhưng
mà với những cái mô hình tôi nó sẽ khác
loại. Ví dụ tôi dùng mix giữa decision
tre và và linear reaction hoặc logistic
reaction chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy các
bạn chẽ thấy thì mình bỏ cái thanh kia
đi nhìn cho dễ nhé.
Rồi
được chưa? Thì bây giờ ấy với stacking ấ
là lúc ban đầu ấy tôi sẽ
tôi sẽ dùng những cái mô hình đơn giản
người ta là base model để tôi huấn luyện
những cái mô hình con này được chưa? Tôi
huấn luyện những cái mô hình con và mô
hình con này thường nó sẽ cái loại khác
nhau chứ nó không phải cùng một cái
disentry nh những cái phiên bản trương
nữa. Được chưa?
Sau đó thì tôi sẽ phải sau khi tôi đã có
những cái base model ví dụ cái mô hình
đầu tiên là mô hình đầu tiên là decision
tre mô hình thứ hai là logistic version
m sau là những mô hình gì đấy đúng không
mỗi ông một kiểu. Được chưa? Tôi tôi
huấn luyện xong rồi và chúng sẽ ra những
dự đoán này. Sau đó tôi sẽ phải huấn
luyện một cái mô hình tiếp theo gọi là
metamodel. Cái mô hình này nó sẽ học cái
gì? Cái mô hình này nó sẽ học cách làm
sao nó có thể thay đổi những cái trọng
số W1 W2 W3 này để sao tôi tổng kết. Tức
là W1, W2, W3, W45 là cái trọng số được
tính từ những cái dự đoán của những này.
Cái metamer này nó phải làm sao? Nó thay
đổi những trọng số này để làm sao nó ra
kết quả nó càng chính xác thì càng tốt.
Được chưa? Những cái trọng số này nó sẽ
tùy bài toán phân loại nó sẽ khác, bài
toán hồi quy nó sẽ khác. Nhưng tóm lại
là gì? Là cái met vì sao gọi là metam
model? Tại vì input của nó ấy không phải
là cái input gốc ban đầu mà input của nó
là cái dự đoán của các cái mô hình cơ
bản này. Được chưa? nó sẽ nó tìm cách nó
tổng hợp những cái kết quả của những này
giống như kiểu này. Base model là giống
kiểu nhân viên. Nhân viên là phải lấy
cái rượu gốc ban đầu để làm việc. Mỗi
ông ra một cái báo cáo. Được chưa? Base
model là năm ông nhân viên khác nhau.
Mỗi ông nhận cùng cái báo cáo này các
ông phải xử lý khác nhau. Được chưa?
>> [khịt mũi]
>> Ông làm gì ông ra cái báo cáo. Còn
metamoder giống như kiểu ông sếp ấy, ông
trưởng phòng ấy, ông trưởng phòng này
không bao giờ phải đi ngồi làm những cái
rượu gốc ban đầu mà ông trưởng phòng mới
chỉ tổng hợp từ những cái báo cáo để ra
cái inside ra kết quả cuối cùng thôi.
Thì đấy là cách hoạt động của stacking
được chưa? Tôi đ sẽ theo hai tầng. Tầng
đầu tiên là base model là những cái mô
hình cơ bản làm việc trực tiếp với input
đầu vào. Còn cái level thứ hai là metam
model là chỉ có một mô hình thôi. Nó sẽ
làm việc trực tiếp với các cái dự đoán
của các cái base model để tổng kết lại
ra được cái dự đoán cuối cùng. Được
chưa? Đấy, nhân trưởng phòng ở dưới này,
nhân viên ở trên này. Được chưa? Cái th
này người ta gọi là stacking. Với
stacking thì người ta sẽ mix các cái
base model, tức là các cái kiểu khác
nhau. Không, tức là thông thường chúng
ta sẽ thuộc về nhiều kiểu. Ví dụ trong
năm mô hình này có thể là hai cái
decision tre, hai cái logistic question
với cả một cái nice chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như
vậy được chưa? đấy là stacking
một cái loại cuối cùng nữa. Loại này nó
sẽ có một loại nữa nó ít phổ biến hơn
người ta gọi là voting. Cái voting này
thì đến cuối đến hôm nào chúng ta tự
hành mình có thời gian mình sẽ chia sẻ
các bạn thêm nhá. Cái voting thì nó sẽ
ít phổ biến hơn. Chúng ta có ba kỹ thuật
chính là gì? Là packing, boosting và
stacking. Đây là ba kỹ thuật được sử
dụng nhiều nhất. Trong mỗi một kỹ thuật
này lại có nhiều những kỹ thuật toán con
ở bên trong các bạn nhá. Đây là tên của
các cái phương pháp khác nhau chứ đây
không phải tên của ngon cụ thể. Được
chưa? Đây không phải là tên của một
thuật toán cụ thể. Ví dụ trong backing
có rất nhiều thuật toán nhưng thuật toán
nổi tiếng nhất là nó nằm for. Được chưa?
Trong boosting cũng có rất nhiều thuật
toán, rất nhiều thuật toán khác nhau và
trong stacking cũng có rất nhiều thuật
toán. Được chưa? Nhưng mà điểm chung của
chúng là gì? Đều dựa trên việc là tôi
kết hợp nhiều mô hình yếu để tôi có thể
cải thiện được cái performance của mô
hình. Được chưa?
Rồi. Ok. Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Không.
Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
>> Em hỏi được không ạ?
>> Em nói to một tí được không?
>> Em em hỏi được không thầy?
>> Ừ ừ em hỏi thoải mái chứ.
>> À em hỏi là thầy giới thiệu rất nhiều
các cái loại mình để mình c thiệp khác
nhau ấy thì trong một bài toán ví dụ
classification hoặc là bài toán bài toán
hồi quy thì mình phải áp dụng tất cả cái
này không? Nhưng mà tiêu chí nào để mình
chọn từng cái này mô hình của mình đấy?
>> Có cái tiêu chí thứ nhất là dựa vào cái
hôm nọ chúng ta vừa học liên quan đến
corelation hệ số tương quan đúng không?
Nếu một bộ dữ liệu mà chúng ta có một
hoặc là một vài những cái feature có cái
hệ số tương quan lớn với target thì
người ta sẽ có xu hướng người ta chọn
những cái thoi toán đơn giản ví dụ như
là linear version hoặc là logistic
version được chưa? Còn nếu cái bộ rượu
mà chẳng có cái feature nào có hệ số
tương quan lớn với tit thì người ta sẽ
chọn cái mô hình phức tạp hơn cái mô
hình phi tuyến. Được chưa? Tất nhiên là
trong tuyến tính chúng ta cũng có rất
nhiều thuật toán. Trong phi tuyến có rất
nhiều thuật toán thì sau này chúng ta sẽ
phải dựa vào những cái yếu tố như là số
lượng sample
hoặc là cái đặc trưng cái cái đặc trưng
các cái đặc điểm của cái bộ rượu đấy.
Hoặc cái cách đơn giản là gì? Cái đơn
giản là chúng ta sẽ chạy nhiều mô hình
thôi rồi chúng ta xoay với nhau. Các cái
thuật toán trong machining, cái thu toán
machining truyền thống ấy đều có đặc
điểm là gì? Là chạy rất là nhanh. Thường
là chạy rất là nhanh. Các bạn không cần
có GPU các bạn cũng chạy được. Nên một
cách đơn giản là gì? Là sau khi tôi đã
thu gọn được là gì? thì tôi chọn cái t
toán tuyến tính hay là phi tuyến rồi thì
tôi sẽ chạy nhiều mô hình để xem là mô
hình nào có cái performance tốt nhất
thôi. Được chưa?
Vậy là
thế nào để ta biết được cái việc có
metà?
Làm thế nào để ta biết được cái việc có
base model với chúng ta sẽ base model
với chúng tôi sẽ hiệu quả. Với việc lại
stacking thì các model sẽ được train
trên tập train hay là tập con.
Cái stacking này các cái tập con này sẽ
được trên tập trang các bạn nhá. Cái
stacking này là nó sẽ cái cái stacking
của chúng ta là chúng ta sẽ được huấn
luyện với toàn bộ dữ liệu các bạn nhá.
Thì những cái mô hình này nhìn chung là
nó sẽ khác loại nhau, khác loại nhau nên
là cái việc mà tôi không phải lo là học
cùng một cái dữ liệu nó sẽ bị có vấn đề
trùm lặp gì với nhau. Được chưa? Second
là dùng toàn bộ dữ liệu của chúng ta.
Được chưa?
Làm sao để biết dễ lắm. Muốn biết được
muốn biết được cái việc dùng base model
kết hợp với meta model này nó có tốt hơn
hay không ấy tôi so sánh được không các
bạn? bảo stacking so các bạn muốn biết
là stacking với cả dùng mỗi decision tre
cái nào tốt hơn so sánh huấn luyện một
lần về decision tree và huấn luyện một
lần về stacking xem cái nào tốt hơn là
biết thôi mà đúng không muốn biết tốt
hơn hay không chỉ cho so sánh thôi được
chưa
rồi ai có câu hỏi giống kiểu ngoài đợi
này thôi muốn biết hai ông nào ông nào
giỏi hơn thì đi thi đi th ông nào điểm
cao hơn thì ông đấy giỏi hơn này được
chưa
>> cái based model sẽ là nhiều cái model
khác loại đúng không thầy Không phải như
kiểu random forest.
>> Đúng rồi. Không phải như kiểu random
forest không phải như kiểu boosting với
cả backing là cùng một loại. Các cái
base model này là khác loại nhau. Có thể
là một ông là decision, một ông là night
bas, một ông là logistic version. Như
vậy
rồi có bắt nào có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Backing, boosting hay là stacking thì
đều tóm lại là đều là kết hợp sức mạnh
của nhiều mô hình yếu để tôi có thể cải
thiện kết quả. Được chưa?
Tiếp này. Đây là một cái trường phái rất
là phổ biến trong machining. Tại vì
trong machining ấy thường các cái thuật
toán thường kích thước nó không có lớn.
Linear hay là logistic question kích
thước nó đều không lớn, nó chỉ có khoảng
vài tham số, vài chục tham số thôi. Nó
rất là bé đúng không? Do đó thì cái việc
các bạn kết hợp nhiều mô hình này là khả
thi. Sau này các bạn học lên ví dụ bạn
nào học lên khóa sau học về de các bạn
thấy là trong deep learning cái thật các
cái kiến trúc ấy nó toàn đến vài vài
triệu tham số, vài chục triệu tham số
thì cái việc này nó sẽ là không thể
không thể kết hợp nhiều cái mô hình như
vậy được. Tại vì chạy một mô hình thôi
đã rất là tốn thời gian rồi. Nhưng trong
machining truyền thống thể làm được như
vậy. Được chưa? Các thong trong machine
truyền thống chạy nó rất là nhanh. Nó
chi các bạn chạy tích tắc nó xong rồi
được chưa? Bổ rượu bạn có vài triệu
sample có khi chạy vài phút là xong. Nó
rất là nhanh nên là nó cho phép các bạn
có thể kết hợp nhiều mô hình con lại để
có thể cải thiện performance của mô
hình. Được chưa?
Tiếp nhá. Thế bây giờ chúng ta sẽ cùng
nhau nói về một toàn toán tiếp theo. Đây
là một toán nó rất là hay. Hình dân mình
học mình rất là thích thu toán này. Nó
khá là khó hiểu. T nó khá là khó hiểu
nhưng mà nó có cái hiệu ứng thị giác rất
là thú vị. Tán này tên là support vector
machine. Được chưa? Tức là support
vector machine. Thì bây giờ các bạn cho
mình hỏi nhá. Bây giờ mình hỏi các bạn
câu này. Bây giờ giả sử đi vẫn là bài
toán binary classification nhá. Vẫn là
bài toán binary classification. Thế bây
giờ này, bây giờ giả sử bây giờ mình
muốn sử dụng cái mô hình để có thể phân
biệt giữa
mô hình về trong mảng computer vision
đi, mô hình về ảnh đi. Được chưa? Tôi
muốn [khịt mũi] sử dụng cái mô hình để
làm sao tôi có thể phân biệt được con
lửa về con ngựa. Được chưa? Tôi có một
cái bộ dữ liệu nó sau khi tôi phân chia
thành bộ tren bộ va bộ test rồi thì bộ
trê của tôi tôi có tôi có 2000 ảnh đi
trong đó có 1000 ảnh là ảnh con ngựa và
1000 ảnh là ảnh con lừa được chưa 1000
ảnh ngựa 1000 ảnh lừa thì bây giờ tất
nhiên là bình thường với cái th toán
thông thường ấy tôi sẽ phải dùng toàn bộ
2000 ảnh này để tôi hướng lệ mô hình
được chưa tôi dùng toàn bộ 2000 cái ảnh
của cái bộ train này để tôi hướng lệ mô
hình nhưng b câu hỏi mình là gì là bây
giờ nếu nếu bây giờ mình muốn là tôi vẫn
vẫn huấn luyện mô hình nhưng tôi không
muốn dùng toàn bộ 2000 ảnh để tôi huấn
luyện. Tôi chỉ muốn chọn ra một cái tập
con tiêu biểu nhất để tôi huấn luyện
thôi. Thì các bạn cho mình hỏi này, theo
các bạn bây giờ ví dụ mình muốn huấn
luyện một cái mô hình phân biệt giữa ảnh
ngựa với ảnh lừa và tôi không dùng toàn
bộ 2000, tôi chỉ muốn chọn ra tập con.
Ví dụ tôi mình chỉ muốn chọn ra là 10
cái ảnh con ngựa và 10 ảnh con lừa thôi.
Theo các bạn thì mình nên chọn ra những
ảnh như nào để quá trình huấn luyện nó
tốt nhất.
Bây giờ tôi sẽ không dùng toàn bộ dữ
liệu, tôi dùng cái tập con thôi. Thì
cách chọn tập con này tôi nên chọn như
thế nào?
>> Chọn mấy con lừa giống ngựa nhất và ngựa
giống lừa nhất.
>> À đúng rồi, chính xác đúng không? Tức là
gì? Tôi sẽ chọn những cái simple nào nó
dễ bị nhầm nhất. Tại vì sao? Tại vì nó
dư cái ý tưởng là gì? Nó dưên cái ý
tưởng là nếu cái mô hình của tôi nó đã
có khả năng, nó phân biệt những cái cây
khó rồi thì sau này những cây dễ hơn nó
cũng sẽ làm được. Giống như kiểu các bạn
đi học ngày xưa ấy đúng không? Ông nào
mà học lớp chuyên lớp chọn đúng không?
Ông nào học chuyên toán chẳng hạn thì
người ta thường người ta mặc định là gì?
Đã học chuyên toán rồi đúng không? Đã đi
thi học sinh giỏi rồi thì những cái bài
thi đại trà cũng thường sức làm được
đúng không? Thì đây cái mô hình nó cũng
như vậy. Thế bây giờ thay vì tôi dùng
toàn bộ semble mà tôi chỉ chọn cái tập
con thôi đấy thì tôi sẽ muốn chọn những
cái sle nào nó dễ bị nhầm nhất đúng
không? Tôi chọn những con ngựa mà giống
lừa nhất. Chọn những con lừa giống ngựa
nhất đúng không? Thì cái ý tưởng này đây
chính là cái ý tưởng nền tảng của một
cái thuật toán rất là thú vị trong
machining. Nó tên là support vector
machine. Ví dụ trong cái hình này các
bạn thấy ở đây đúng không? Tôi có hai
cái class, một class hình tròn và một
class hình sao đúng không? Thì bây giờ
ấy tôi muốn tôi muốn làm gì? Tôi muốn là
tôi làm sao tôi có thể tôi kẻ được một
cái đường phân cách để nó có thể để nó
có thể phân chia các cái C1 này về hai
phía của cái đường thẳng đó. Đúng không?
Tôi muốn kẻ một cái đường phân cách như
vậy. Ví dụ đây là một đường đúng không?
Ví dụ đây là một đường như vậy đúng
không? Đây là một đường phân cách nó
phân chia rượu tôi về hai phía đúng
không? Và đây là một đường khác đúng
không? Cái đường màu tím nó là một đường
và đường màu cam nó là một đường khác
đúng không? Tôi sẽ có thể vẽ vẽ được vô
số đường như vậy đúng không? Tôi có thể
vẽ được vô số cái đường thẳng để nó có
thể phân chia rượu tôi nằm về hai phí
của đường thẳng đó. Được chưa? Thế ví dụ
đây mình ví dụ đây mình chỉ lấy hai
đường thẳng như này thôi. Được chưa? Thì
các bạn cho mình hỏi này. Theo các bạn
theo cái cảm nhận về mặt thị giác của
các bạn theo các bạn hai cái đường này
đường nào phân chia tốt hơn? Và lý do là
vì sao?
Theo các bạn hai cái đường này, đường
nào phân chia dữ liệu tốt hơn? Và lý do
là vì sao?
Các bạn thấy đường màu tím phân chia tốt
hơn hay là đường màu cam phân chia tốt
hơn? Và lý do vì sao các bạn lại nghĩ
như thế?
Đường nào tốt hơn?
Đường nào tốt hơn hả các bạn? Màu tím
với màu cam. Các bạn thấy cái nào tốt
hơn?
Cả hai đường đều phân chia một cách
perfect đúng không?
Đường một cái cả hai đường đều đều đường
thẳng mà. Hai ông đều đường thẳng hết.
Tím cũng thẳng mà cam cũng thẳng. Chả
chả ông nào cong ở đây cả. Hai ông đều
thẳng. Được chưa? Hai ông này đều thẳng
đúng không [khịt mũi] các bạn? Nhìn này.
Hai cái đường này ấy thì nó đều
này hai cái đường này ấy thì nó đều phân
chia dữ liệu một cách perfect không có
lỗi. Nhưng đường màu tím nó sẽ tốt hơn.
Tại vì sao? Tại vì thứ nhất là trông nó
có vẻ cách đều các cái symbol gần nhất
thuộc về hai class đều hơn đúng không?
Ví dụ cái đường cái một class màu xanh
này đúng không? Cái lá hình hình tròn
đây là cái điểm này nó cách và một cam
mà cái hình xa này nó cách có vẻ nó đều
hơn đúng không? Thứ hai là nó tối đa hóa
cái khoảng cách. Ví dụ cái màu cam này
nó cái đường này nó gần quá đúng không?
Gần này nó không tốt. Tại vì sao? Tại vì
trong tương lai ấy nếu có những cái điểm
sample mới ở đây ấ thì cái đường màu tím
này nó sẽ dễ đúng hơn đường màu cam nó
sẽ dễ sai hơn đúng không? Cái đường này
của tôi ấy mà càng gần với các cái
sample thuộc hai cái lá này là điều
không tốt đúng không? Cách nó càng xa
thì càng tốt. Cách càng xa thì trong
tương lai có cái điểm mới vào tôi sẽ dễ
dự nó đúng hơn. Được chưa? Thế các bạn
nhìn này. Thế thì
những cái những cái đường thẳng mà dùng
để phân cách dữ liệu chúng ta về hai
phía này ấy thì cái này trong người ta
gọi là người ta gọi là hyperplane.
Hyperplane người ta gọi là siêu phẳng.
Được chưa? Hyperplane đây mình viết đây
nhá. Hyper plan là mặt phẳng thì hyper
plane ơ rồi sao mình không gõ rồi đấy ạ?
Mình không gõ nhỉ?
Bạn chả thấy không biết sao mình phải gõ
từng từng cái một này hyper đây nhá.
Người ta gọi là hyperplane như này được
chưa? Hyperplane gọi là siêu phẳng.
Trong không gian hai chiều thì
hyperplane là một đường thẳng. Được
chưa? Trong không gian hai chiều thì
chưa? Thế thì trong không gian chúng ta
trong cái trường hợp này chúng ta sẽ có
vô số những cái hyperplane này nhưng
trong đó sẽ chỉ có duy nhất một cái
hyperplane là tối ưu mà thôi. Cái hyper
tối ưu nó như này. Nó là cái đường màu
nửa trắng nửa tím này được không? Đây là
cái hyper tối ưu. Tại vì sao? Tại vì nó
thỏa mãn hai điều kiện. Thứ nhất là nó
cách đều những cái điểm gần nhất thuộc
về hai class nhá. Thứ nhất nó cách đều
những cái điểm gần nhất thuộc về hai
class. Ví dụ đây cái class hình tròn tôi
có hai cái điểm gần nhất.
Class màu hình hình hình hình hình sao
tôi có một điểm đúng không? Khoảng cách
đường này đến hai cái đường đấy nó đều
nhau được chưa? Tức là nó đều thứ hai là
khoảng cách này nó nó tối đa đều là chưa
đủ tại vì đều thì có thể là ông ông màu
ông màu cam này cũng đều đây này. Ông
gần nhất đây đây đúng không? Hôm này
cách và nó đều khoảng cách này đúng
không? Đều là chưa đủ nhưng mà cái
khoảng cách nó phải là tối đa nữa đúng
không? Thì tôi sẽ chỉ có một duyết cái
đường như vậy thôi. Thì cái đường này
người ta gọi là optimal hyperplane nó
thỏa mãn hai điều kiện. Thứ nhất nó cách
đều những cái điểm gần nhất thuộc về hai
class. Và thứ hai là gì? Nó đảm bảo cái
khoảng cách đấy là khoảng cách tối đa.
Được chưa? Thì đây đây trên cái ví dụ
các bạn tưởng tượng là cái hình tròn này
là cái class hình con ngựa này. Hình xa
là class hình con lừa đúng không? Thì
bây giờ các bạn chú ý này. Rõ ràng là
gì? Là cái phương trình của cái đường
hyperplane này, phương trình của cái
đường thẳng này ấy đúng không? Nó chỉ
phụ thuộc vào những cái điểm gần nhất
thuộc về hai class thôi. Được chưa? Cái
phương trình của đường này nó hoàn toàn
chỉ dựa vào những cái điểm gần nhất
thuộc về hai class thôi. Có những cái
điểm xa hơn nó chả phụ thuộc gì cả. Được
chưa? Những điểm xơ nó có ảnh hưởng gì
đâu. Nó có phụ thuộc gì đâu. Được chưa?
Nó cũng giống như cái ví dụ vừa rồi đúng
không? Tôi có 1000 ảnh cho con ngựa,
1000 ảnh cho con lừa. Nhưng mà thật ra
ấy những cái ảnh nó thực sự nó quyết
định cái phương trình đường thẳng tôi nó
chỉ có một ít thôi đúng không? Đây tôi
chỉ có hai điểm này với một điểm này tôi
chỉ có ba điểm thôi. Đúng không? Thì
những cái điểm này người ta gọi chúng là
support vector. Được chưa? Những cái
điểm như thế này ấy người ta gọi là
support vector. Thuật toán này được gọi
là support vector machine. Được chưa?
Phương trình của cái hyp của tôi được
quyết định hoàn toàn dựa vào các support
vector là những cái điểm dữ liệu gần
nhất mà thôi, đúng không? Đây chính là
những cái ông dễ bị sai nhất đúng không?
Nhưng cái ông càng gần cái đường này thì
càng là ông càng dễ sai đúng không? Càng
gần cái đường phân cách của chúng ta thì
là cái thứ càng dễ sai. Còn mấy ông ở xa
này thì nó dễ rồi. M ông xa này cách xa
này nó dễ rồi đúng không? Ông nào càng
gần này thì càng dễ sai. Thì bây giờ là
sao? tôi xây dựng cái đường làm sao tôi
một cái hyper lane làm sao tôi chỉ dựa
vào những cái này thôi. Tôi chỉ dựa vào
những cái điểm khó nhất thôi. Tại vì
sao? Nếu tôi đã phân chia được những
điểm khó nhất rồi thì những điểm dễ hơn
tôi sẽ tất nhiên là tôi sẽ phân chia
được đúng không? Thì đấy chính là cái ý
tưởng đầu tiên của support vector
machine. Được chưa? Dựa vào việc là tôi
sẽ tối đa hóa khoảng cách từ cái
hyperplane của tôi đến các cái điểm gần
nhất thuộc về hai class
đúng không? Tối đa làm chuyện và có vẻ
phải đều nữa. Tại vì sao? Cái đường này
các bạn tịnh tiến lên xuống thì cũng
được thôi nhưng mà tịnh tiến lên xuống
như vậy thì nó sẽ không còn đều nữa đúng
không? Nó phải tối đa và nó phải đều. Nó
phải tối đa và nó phải đều. Được chưa?
Đấy là cái thứ nhất. Rồi đến đây có bạn
nào có câu hỏi
>> th trong cái trường hợp về giữa điệu ảnh
này thì cái x1 x2 này cụ thể nó là cái
gì vậy? Nó là hai cái feature đồ vào. Nó
là hai cái feature đồ vào. Nó cũng là
feature đây. Tất cả chúng đây feure nó
giống như này này. Giống như giống như
đây. H income student kiểu kiểu như vậy.
N chúng ta đều nói lại chúng ta phân
chia đều phải dựa vào feature mà.
Feature là cái thông tin đầu vào đúng
không? Chúng ta phải dựa vào feature để
chúng ta đưa dự án. Thì đây x12 nó là
hai cái feature gì đây? Ví dụ là một cái
là một cái là về tuổi, một cái là về
lương chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như thế. Thế nếu
nói về dữ liệu ảnh thì nó là cái gì?
ảnh nó là những cái pixel này là những
cái pixel pixel của cái ảnh đấy
pixel nó pixel của ảnh đều giá trị từ 0
đến 255 mà
>> thế tức là ví dụ như nó sẽ dùng cái
pixel đấy xong rồi nó sẽ nói ví dụ như
là
ờ con lừa thì nhỏ hơn con ngựa hay là
như nào hay là ờ nó dựa vào độ lớn của
pixel trong khái niệm ảnh ấy thì ví dụ
ảnh đen trắng các cái pixel chạy từ 0
cho đến 255 càng gần không thì càng gần
màu đen
càng gần 25 càng gần màu trắng.
Hoặc là ảnh màu thì nó sẽ mỗi một cái
điểm mỗi một cái pixel sẽ được hiện bằng
một cái vecor có ba phần tử. Ví dụ là
màu đỏ thì là 0 à 25500. Ví dụ như vậy
thì tố lại tấm lại thì tức là tôi sẽ có
hai cái feature và bây giờ tôi muốn làm
sao tôi phân tách tôi dựa vào cái giá
trị của hai feature này đúng không?
Trong chiều pixel nó sẽ có nhiều nó sẽ
có nhiều pixel tôi sẽ không tôi sẽ không
vẽ được trong không gian hai chiều nhưng
mà nó sẽ có nhiều chiều hơn nhưng mà cái
ý tưởng nó vẫn là như thế tôi vẫn muốn
có một cái gì đấy để tôi phân cách trùng
ra đúng không? Ví dụ là ảnh con ngự ngựa
thì nó thường là màu sáng, ảnh màu con
lừa nó thường màu tối chẳng hạn. Ví dụ
là như vậy đó.
>> Rồi
>> ở đây mình tạm hiểu là là mỗi cái bức
ảnh ấ nó là một ma trận. Ví dụ như là nó
là 1000 nhân 1000 pixel đúng không?
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Thì mỗi mỗi pixel đấy nó là một tập của
không gian ba chiều gọi là là nhà RBG
đúng không?
>> Đúng rồi. Chính xác.
>> Đó. Đấy. Thế thì
lúc đấy thì cái thể hiện cái sự khác
biệt giữa hai cái bức ảnh khác nhau ấy
để thể hiện nó thuộc hai class khác nhau
ấy, nó sẽ phụ thuộc vào các cái feature
khác nhau của cái bức ảnh đó.
>> Chính là giá trị của các cái pixel của
feature khác nhau của pixel của bức ảnh
đó.
>> Chính là giá trị của pixel. Chính là giá
trị của pixel.
>> Chính là giá trị của pixel.
>> Ừ.
Như khi nào thực hành mình cái dữ liệu
điện ảnh nó là cái gì đấy anh chị không
nó không cụ thể lắm. Ví dụ như là mình
nói về mấy người cho vay nó có mấy cái
nó rất là cụ thể mình nhìn thấy mình đ
>> mình hiểu được như thế nhưng mà liên
quan giữa cái dữ liệu ảnh và cái phân
biệt là cái con gì. Chị chưa thấy cái
mối tương quan giữa hai cái đó lắm. Có
thể là lúc mình thực hành mối tương quan
giữa cái gì và cái gì ạ? V một cái ảnh
màu tối một ảnh màu sáng thì sao mình
biết là con ngựa hay là con lừa đấy nó
chụp ngoài nắng nó chụp trong tối nó
khác gì nhau chị
>> đấy là cái cái
>> cái đấy là việc của mô hình chứ không
phải việc của mình mình đang cái đấy là
việc của mô hình đấy không phải việc của
mình đấy là việc mô hình nó sẽ phải tìm
ra cách nó phân chia được góc nhìn của
mô hình và góc nhìn có người nó khác
nhau chẳng qua đây mình lấy cái ví dụ
minh họa để các bạn hiểu là cái ý tưởng
của tôi là gì tức là lấy ví dụ có lừa
ngựa không phải là để là tôi bắt cái mô
hình nó phải phân loại ảnh tức là ý tôi
là bây giờ mình muốn phân loại tức là
bây giờ mình muốn huấn luyện cái mô hình
của tôi với ít rượu hơn thì tôi sẽ phải
chọn ra những cái sample mà nó dễ bị
nhầm nhất. Cái ý tưởng nó như vậy thôi.
Còn nó có thể áp dụng cho nhiều bài toán
ví dụ lấy ảnh gì cho nó khổ ra đúng
không? Bây giấy chờ đơn giản là gì? Bây
giờ ví dụ là lấy tuổi và lương chẳng hạn
cho nó dễ đúng không? Ảnh nó có rất
nhiều pixel nó sẽ khó hình dung hơn đúng
không? Lấy cái trường hợp nó dễ hơn. Tức
là dù là bài dù là cái bài to bài toán
nào ý tưởng là gì là b tôi muốn tìm một
cái đường phân cách để tôi phân chia nó
ra thành hai phía. Thế còn cụ thể cái
tiêu chí là cái tiêu chí ví dụ con người
chúng ta chúng ta dựa vào chúng ta biết
nhận thức là ngựa như nào, lừa như nào
nhưng mà mô hình nó sẽ có cái hình dung
khác, mô hình nó sẽ làm khác. Máy nó
hiểu dữ liệu khác với con người. Con
người chúng ta sẽ hiểu dữ liệu nhiều
dạng khác nhau. Máy nó hiểu dữ dạng số
thôi. Đấy chúng ta không phải cần phải
phân tích v sao là vì sao máy nó làm
kiểu gì. Tại vì là cách máy mà con người
nó nhận nó không giống nhau. Bây giờ
mình có giải thích cho mọi người là phân
biệt như thế nào thì chưa chắc đấy là
cách máy nó làm đúng không? Thì các bạn
biết là nói về ngữ lập tập trình nó ngôn
lập trình bậc cao là cho con người hiểu
và ngũ lập trình bậc thấp cho máy nó
hiểu. Đấy bản thất chúng ta và máy nó
hiểu nó đã khác nhau rồi. Chúng ta không
thể chúng ta đem cách chúng ta hiểu dữ
liệu để chúng ta ốp vào mô hình. Tại vì
đơn giản mô hình nó sẽ không làm như thế
đúng không? Chúng ta không làm mô hình
nó không là chẳng qua là khi mà chúng ta
học tán chúng ta đưa những cái ví dụ để
chúng ta hình dung là gì? À về mặt lý
thuyết thì
thì thì nó phân loại như thế nào thôi.
Nhưng mà máy nó máy nó làm như thế nào
cụ thể nào chúng ta sẽ không có biết
đúng không? Chúng ta chỉ biết là gì? Máy
nó phải phân chia làm sao để đẩy về hai
phía thôi. Còn cụ thể nó phân chia giữa
tiêu chí là hình dạng hay là kết cấu hay
là kích thước hay là màu sắc. Chúng ta
không có biết cái điều đấy.
>> Tại vì nếu chúng ta biết rồi thì nó chỉ
chạy trên hai feature thôi hay nó chạy
trên có thể trên nhiều có quan trọng
trong đây trường hợp đơn giản ch có hai
feature tí mình sẽ nói trường hợp nhiều
feature nó như thế nào. Tại vì hai
feature nó sẽ dễ dễ vẽ lên đồ thị nên
người ta thường hay dùng là ví dụ là
high feature tất cả những trường hợp ví
dụ các cái trường hợp này cái trường hợp
chúng ta học về linear với cả logistic
này. À đây
về mặt bản chất thì linear reaction nó
nó đâu bị giới hạn đâu. Nhưng mà thông
thường khi người ta minh họa người ta
hay trong không gian hai chiều để cho nó
dễ nhìn đúng không? Còn ba bốn chiều
chúng ta không vẽ được đúng không? Nhiều
chiều nữa chúng ta không vẽ được chứ còn
bản chất đán này không gian bao nhiêu
chiều nó cũng làm được đúng không? Thì
tất cả toàn chúng ta, tất cả đệ toàn
chúng ta học từ đầu đến giờ ấy chúng nó
đều không bị giới hạn về số lượng chiều.
Nhưng mà chẳng qua khi học ấy người ta
hay ưu tiên người ta vẽ trong gian hai
chiều để cho nó dễ chưa. Thì Dion Stream
nó cũng y chang như vậy. Nhiều chiều nữa
nó cũng làm được nhưng mà nhiều hơn thì
tôi không vẽ được thôi nhá.
Rồi
có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Anh nhá. Cái ví dụ vừa rồi ấ mình lấy
cho mọi người ví dụ là lừa với cả ngựa
ấy để các bạn hình dung là cái ý tưởng
là tôi sẽ phải tôi cố gắng tôi phân chia
cho những cái x khó nhất thôi chứ không
phải là vì mình bảo là lừa với ngựa là
các bạn bắt buộc các bạn phải làm sao
các bạn đưa lừa với ngựa về x1 với x2
đâu. Không phải như vậy đúng không? Đây
tán nó áp dụng trong nhiều bài toán khác
nhau. Không phải là chỉ có ảnh đâu nhá.
Rồi thứ nhất là như vậy đúng không? Thứ
nhất cái ý tưởng là như vậy đúng không?
Tôi phải tìm ra được một cái optimal
hyperplane để tôi có thể phân chia rượu
tôi một cách rõ nhất đúng không? Trong
trường này tôi chỉ có x1, x2 thôi đúng
không? Tôi chỉ có x1, x2 thôi nhưng mà
trong trường khác sẽ có nhiều x hơn.
Được chưa? Thế [khịt mũi] nhưng mà thế
nhưng mà cái vấn đề ở đây là gì? Là là
không phải lúc nào dữ liệu của tôi tôi
cũng có thể dễ dàng tôi kẻ một cái đường
thẳng để tôi phân chia như vậy. Ví dụ
các bạn nhìn nhá, ở cái hình bên trái
này đúng không? Vẫn là trong không gian
hai chiều đây. Đúng không? Đây là không
gian hai chiều. Hình bên trái này, cái
mặt phẳng này nó cũng là không gian hai
chiều đúng không? Trong không gian hai
chiều này các bạn có vẽ kiểu rời, các
bạn có vẽ cái đường thẳng kiểu rời đi
nữa thì cũng sẽ không thể nào các bạn
phân chia dữ liệu được. Được chưa? Trong
cái không dân hai chiều này các bạn có
muốn vẽ kiểu gì nữa các bạn cũng sẽ
không thể nào các bạn có khả năng các
bạn phân chia các cái điểm dựa này nằm
về hai phía cũng được đường thẳng. Các
bạn thử vẽ mà xem đúng không? Vẽ kiểu gì
cũng không phân chia được. Được chưa?
Thế thì bây giờ ấy cái đặc điểm thứ hai
của support vector machine là cái gì? Đó
là nếu trong cái không gian gốc ban đầu
tôi không có thể nào tôi phân chia rượu
của tôi được thì tôi sẽ đưa cái rượu tôi
đang từ không gian ít chiều lên thành
không gian nhiều chiều. Và trong không
gian nhiều tất nhiên là không gian chiều
nhiều chiều này tô phải tạo ra những cái
chiều mới đúng không? Tôi sẽ phải làm
sao? Tôi tìm cách tôi tạo ra những cái
chiều mới để làm sao cái chiều mới này
nó lại giúp tôi có thể phân chia rượu
của tôi được. Được chưa? Thì bây giờ ví
dụ ở đây đúng không? Ví dụ đây tôi giả
sử tôi đã tìm được một cái chiều mới tôi
thêm vào và khi thêm một cái chiều mới
này nó như thế này đúng không? Thì bây
giờ trong cái trâm chiếu mới này tôi có
thể tôi tìm được cái m phẳng phân chia
rượu tôi thành về hai phía này. Thì các
bạn chú ý này, vì sao vừa nãy người ta
lại gọi là hyperplane mà người ta lại
không gọi là đường thẳng? Tại vì ý tại
vì là hyperplane không phải lúc nào cũng
là đường thẳng. Hyperplane nó chỉ là
đường thẳng trong trường hợp là không
gian hai chiều thôi. Trong không gian
hai chiều thì hyperplane là một đường
thẳng. Trong không gian ba chiều thì
hyperplane là một mặt phẳng. Mặt phẳng
màu vàng thế này được chưa? Số chiều của
hyperplane bao giờ cũng ít hơn số chiều
của không gian là 1. Ví dụ trong không
gian hai chiều thì hyperplane là một
đường thẳng. Đường thẳng là chỉ có một
chiều thôi đúng không? Đường thẳng là
một chiều,
mặt phẳng là hai chiều,
hình khối là ba chiều đúng không? Thế
thì trong không gian mà hai chiều thì
hai số chiều của hyperben là 1. Trong
không gian mà ba chiều thì số chiều của
hyperben là 2. Đúng không? Trong không
gian n chiều thì số chiều của hyperplane
là n - 1 đúng không? Số chiều của
hyperplane bao giờ cũng ít hơn số chiều
của không gian là 1 đúng không? Và
hyperplane không phải lúc nào cũng là
đường thẳng. Thế nên người ta không gọi
là line, người ta không gọi là đường
thẳng mà người ta gọi là hyperplane.
Được chưa?
Trong không gian ba chiều hyperl nó
trông nó như thế này được chưa? Nó trông
như này thì đấy là cái ý tưởng của
support vector machine. Tức là gì? Nếu ở
trong không gian gốc tôi không phân chia
rượu của tôi một cách tuyến tính được
thì tôi sẽ đẩy nó lên trong không gian
nhiều chiều hơn. Được chưa? Nhiều chiều.
Mình chưa hề nói đến giảm chiều, mình
chỉ nói đến tăng chiều thôi đúng không?
Mình chưa hề đề cập đến giảm chiều đúng
không? Mình chỉ nói với tăng chiều thôi
đúng không? Chiều gốc ban đầu còn không
phân chia nổi làm sao mà giảm đi được
đúng không? Không gian hai chiều mà còn
không phiên chia nổi giảm đi làm sao mà
phân chia được đúng không? Phải tăng lên
mới mới phân chia được đúng không? Hai
chiều còn không phân được thì đưa về một
chiều làm sao mà phân nổi đúng không?
Phải tăng số chiều lên đúng không? Và
trong thực tế không phải cứ tăng một
chiều là đã đủ đâu. Có khi người ta phải
tăng hai ba chiều nhưng mà tăng như nào
thì phải tăng như th nào ấy thì nó còn
nó còn tùy thuộc. Ví dụ cho mình cho các
bạn xem nhá. Ví dụ như này nhá. Ví dụ
như này này. Ví dụ đây nhá. Ví dụ như
này. Bây giờ như này này nhá. Tôi có một
cái không gian trong phan gian hai chiều
này được chưa? Không gian hai chiều vẽ
này đánh không gian hai chiều đi. Được
chưa? Đây là x1 này. Đây là x2 nhá. Được
chưa? X1 x2 nhá. Các bạn nhìn này. Bây
giờ tôi sẽ có bốn cái điểm như này. Hai
điểm O như này và hai điểm X như này.
Được chưa? X này của tôi độ là 1 1. Ông
này tọa độ là 1 - 1. Ông này là -1 - 1.
Và ông này là -1 1. Được chưa? Bộ đông
như này. Được chưa? Trong không gian hai
chiều như này thì các bạn có vẽ kiểu rời
các bạn cũng không thể nào các bạn phân
chia được cái điểm diện này. Được chưa?
Vẽ kiểu gì cũng không gi phân kiểu gì
đâu. Đây phân này không không phân được
đúng không? Phân này đúng không? Không
thể nào các bạn có thể phân chia được dữ
liệu trong không gian hai chiều này đúng
không? Thì bây giờ tôi mới có ý tưởng là
gì? Là tôi sẽ phải đưa nó lên thành
không gian ba chiều. Được chưa? Mình vẽ
màu khác đi nhìn nó dễ nhá.
Đấy đúng không? Trong công gian hai
chiều này đúng không? Tôi có bốn cái
điểm này. Hai điểm thuộc về class hình
tròn. hai điểm thuộc về class hình dấu
tích này được chưa? Trong không gian hai
chiều tôi không phân chia được thì bây
giờ tôi ý thưởng tôi đưa lên không gian
ba chiều nhưng không gian ba chiều tức
là tôi sẽ phải thêm một cái chiều mới.
Cái chiều mới này nó sẽ là phải nó sẽ
phải một cái tổ hợp gì đấy của những cái
chiều cũ được chưa? Nó có thể là
nó có thể là x1 nó có thể là x1 mũ 3
cộng x2 bình phương. Tức là nó sẽ nó sẽ
là một cái tổ hợp gì? Bất kỳ của những
chiều cũ. Nhưng
thuật toán nó phải tìm ra cái chiều mới
nào mà nó giúp cho cái việc phân chia
đúng không? Tại vì bây giờ ví dụ các bạn
thêm cái chiều mới là
x1 + x2 chẳng hạn thì nó cũng chả rút gì
cả đúng không? Thêm cái chiều mới chiều
x3 đi bằng x1 + x2 nó cũng chả rút cái
gì cả. Được chưa? Thế bây giờ các bạn
cho mình hỏi này, bây giờ đang không
gian hai chiều như này. Bây giờ tôi muốn
đưa lên thành không gian ba chiều đúng
không? Tôi muốn đưa lên thành không gian
ba chiều thì theo các bạn cái chiều mới
nó có công thức là gì thì nó sẽ giúp cho
chúng ta có thể phân chia dữ liệu được.
Đưa lên không gian ba chiều nhá. Không
gian ba chiều như này được chưa? Không
gian ba chiều này
chưa? X1 này, X2 này, được chưa? X3 này.
Được chưa? Cái chiều mới này theo các
bạn nó có công thức là cái gì? Thì nó sẽ
giúp chúng ta có thể đẩy được hai cái
điểm hình tròn về một phía và hai cái
điểm hình dấu nhân kia về một phía của
đường thẳng à của mặt phẳng.
X3 này nó sẽ là phải một cái hàm gì đấy
của
X1 và X2
bằng cái gì? Tích có hướng á. Tích hướng
gì? Tích hướng là cái gì? Mình mình
không hiểu.
>> X1 nh X2
>> à? Đúng rồi. X1 nh X2 đúng không? X1 nh
X2. Vì sao? Các bạn để ý là gì? Hai cái
điểm dấu x này nó cùng dấu đúng không? 1
1 với cả -1 -1 hoành độ tung độ cùng dấu
trong hai ông kia nghịch dấu. Thì bây
giờ ấy nếu tôi thêm cái chiều mới này
đúng không? Bằng x1 nhân với x2 ấy đúng
không? Thì bây giờ các bạn sẽ có cái cao
độ x3 nó sẽ hai cái ông dấu x này nó sẽ
phọt lên trên đây này. Nó sẽ phọt lên
trên này. Đây hai ông x3 nó vọt lên
trên. Được chưa? 3 này. Trong khi là hai
cái ông kia thì nó lại vọt xuống dưới.
Hai ông kia hai ông kia lại xuống dưới
này. Đấy đúng không? Thì bây giờ tôi sẽ
có một cái mặt phẳng ở giữa. Mặt phẳng ở
giữa như này. Mặt phẳng ở giữa như này
này. Đấy được chưa? Mặt này. Đấy.
Đúng không? Nó phân chia về hai phía.
Đúng chưa? Trong không gian hai chiều
gốc ban đầu thì các cái điểm rượu này nó
không phân chia được về hai phía nhưng
trong không gian nhiều chiều hơn lại
phân chia được. Được chưa? Thì đây chính
là cái ý tưởng của support vector
machine đúng không? Đây là ví dụ đơn
giản thêm một chiều thôi là đủ nhưng sẽ
có những chiều nó phức tạp hơn. Các bạn
có nhiều sample hơn, nhiều dữ liệu hơn
thì có thể sẽ phải thêm 2 3 bốn chiều.
Những cái chiều mới này ấ nó sẽ là một
cái hàm gì đấy của các cái chiều cũ. Nó
có thể là hàm đa thức, hàm e, hàm gì đấy
các bạn sẽ không phải ngồi các bạn làm
thủ công đâu. Sau này thư viện nó sẽ làm
cho các bạn. Nhưng mà các bạn hiểu cái
đơn giản là gì n? Tức là support v
machine ấ nó sẽ chủ động nó sẽ thêm các
cái chiều mới vào để giúp cho rượ liệu
ta nó dễ được phân tách hơn. Được chưa?
Dễ được phân tách hơn. Trong không gian
gốc không phân chia được nhưng trong
không gian mới thì phân chia được. Được
chưa? Đấy là cái ý tưởng của support
vector machine. Được chưa? Cái thứ dùng
để phân cách người ta gọi là hyperplane.
Hyperplane bao giờ số chiều cũng ít hơn
không gian là một chiều. Được chưa?
Trong không gian ba chiều thì hyperplane
là một mặt phẳng có hai chiều được chưa?
Trong không gian hai chiều thì
hyperplane là một cái đường thẳng một
chiều được chưa? Đường của sub machine.
Ví dụ bạn nhìn nhá
minh họa này. Minh họa này nhìn nhá.
Không gian gốc ban đầu không phân chia
được. Vẽ đường thẳng kiểu dời cũng không
phân chia được đúng không? Đưa lên không
gian ba chiều này lên không gian ba
chiều này.
Được chưa? Trong không gian ba chiều thì
bây giờ hyperplane nó sẽ là một cái mặt
phẳng.
Đấy trong con dân ba chiều thì đúng
không? Mặt phầng này nó sẽ phân chia dữ
các bạn về xong sau người ta sẽ úp ngực
lại về trong gian hai chiều cho các bạn
xem. Đây
được chưa? Đây là ý tưởng của support
machine. Được chưa?
Đấy đúng không?
Tất nhiên trong thực tế ấ trong thực tế
ấ thì kể cả có thêm rất là nhiều chiều
ấy thì cũng không có gì đảm bảo là dữ
liệu ta nó sẽ có thể phân chia một cách
hoàn hảo. Thế nên là trong thực tế
thường là với support v machine nó sẽ
chịu một cái ngưỡng là ngưỡng lỗi. Tức
là gì? Người ta chấp nhận là gì? Là sau
khi phân chia có thể là có một vài
sample của ông này nằm nhầm vào ông kia
người ta cũng chấp nhận. Tức là ví dụ
gì? Ví dụ là có một cái ngưỡng là hai
phần tử đi. Tức là gì? Tức là nếu phân
chia xong ấy mà số lượng sle của ông này
nằm trong nằm trong cái phía của ông kia
ấy dưới hai phần tử người ta vẫn chấp
nhận được chưa? Đây là sub tức là nó có
hai đặc điểm. Thứ nhất là gì? Là cái ý
tưởng của sub machine là tìm ra được một
cái hyperplane, một cái siêu phẳng tốt
nhất để có thể phân chia dữ liệu. Và đấy
là cái thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai là gì? Là
nếu trong không gian gốc ban đầu ấy dữ
liệu của tôi mà không thể phân chia được
thì tôi sẽ đẩy lên không gian nhiều
chiều hơn. Tất nhiên không phải cái
chiều nào cũng được đúng không? nó sẽ
phải có những cái có những cái chiều nó
phù hợp và những chiều nó không phù hợp
thì các bạn dùng thư viện các bạn cũng
không cần phải quan tâm đến cái bước này
các bạn cũng không trừ khi các bạn đi
theo hướng nghiên cứu the học thuật thì
các bạn mới cần không thì các bạn chỉ có
một cái đơn giản gì là support ver
machine nó sẽ tìm những cái chiều không
gian mới để làm sao khi nó đưa lên chiều
không gian mới này thì dữ liệu nó sẽ
phân chia ra được chưa đấy là ý tưởng
của support vector machine.
Rồi có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không? Có
bạn nào có thắc mắc gì không?
Có bạn nào có thắc mắc gì không?
Cái việc mà xây dựng support vector
machine này ý thì như Việt nói là ừ nó
không hoàn toàn tuyệt đối mà nó có thể
có một số các cái sự gọi là sai lệch
giữa cái việc à
phân từ class này sang class khác ấy.
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Thì thì cái mô hình nó có cho ra được
cái sai số về mặt
support không? Tứ ví dụ như là có tỉ lệ
bao nhiêu phần trăm cái cái a
cái cái cái phần tử trong trong class ý
nó bị lẫn lộn giữa cái cái một và cái
hai không?
>> Cái ngưỡng là do chúng ta đặt ra nhá. Ví
dụ ngưỡng là size 4, size 5, size 6 đúng
không? Tức là maximum chỉ 4 hay 5 hay 6
đúng không? Còn chúng ta muốn biết là có
bao nhiêu cái mà sai thì dễ lắm. Chúng
ta so cái dự đoán của mô hình với cả cái
label thực tế là xong đây mà.
>> Ừ.
>> Đúng không? Chúng ta giống kiểu làm bài
kiểm tra này thôi. Học sinh làm bài ra
cô chấm bài là xong rồi.
>> À
có nghĩa là từ đối trường từ cái cái
phần validation ấ thì mình sẽ xét xem là
test à từ t cái label thực tế đến label
nó do mô hình nó đưa ra ấy cái độ sai số
là bao nhiêu, bao nhiêu phần trăm là
đúng, bao nhiêu giă sai đúng không ạ?
Thế là nếu mình quan tâm nếu mình quan
tâm đến đến cái điều đấy tôi chỉ biết là
tôi để max trong trình huyện tôi để
maximum là gì? Là size số không quá năm.
Tức là gì? Tức là đến cuối cùng với cái
bộ chơi của tôi, tôi yêu cầu là gì? Là
trong cái phía của cái class này không
được có quá năm sy class kia. Thế còn
nếu mà tôi muốn đánh giá cụ thể là bao
nhiêu thì tôi lôi dự đoán về cái label
thực tế ra. Prediction là một bên, label
là một bên. So sánh đối chiếu là sao?
>> À ok.
Không phải đâu em ơi. Không phải nó chỉ
bao nhiêu đâu. Muốn bao nhiêu chiều cũng
được. Chẳng qua nhiều chiều hơn thì
người ta không vẽ được thôi. Cái này
muốn bao nhiêu chiều cũng được hết á.
Lúc ban đầu ấy đây mình chỉ lấy hai
feature là tại vì là không vẽ được thêm.
Bạn muốn mình mình có thể 20 chiều hay
là 200 chiều nó cũng được chẳng qua là
nhiều hơn thì không vẽ được rồi đúng
không? Lý do nhất đây mình vẽ hai chiều
là vì do cái giới hạn về việc vẽ thôi.
Còn không thì nó muốn bao nhiêu chiều
cũng được. Ví dụ gốc ban đầu không phải
nó chỉ có hai chiều, 20, 200, 2 tỷ chiều
cũng được. Có vấn đề này
tất cả các thuật toán trong machining
không thuật toán nào bị giới hạn về số
chiều cả. Chẳng qua trong quá trình học,
trong quá trình viết sách, người ta buộc
phải để trong không gian hai chiều hoặc
kịch kim là ba chiều. Tại vì chúng ta
không có khả năng vẽ trong không gian
nhiều chiều hơn. được không? Và thường
với không gian hai chiều và ba chiều với
người mới học nó mới dễ hình dung đúng
không? Chứ bây giờ mình bảo các bạn
không gian 20 chiều các bạn hình dung
nổi đúng không?
Rồi có ai có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Giống kiểu ngày xưa các bạn học cộng trừ
nhân chia ấ lúc bắt đầu cô phải cho các
bạn cộng trừ trong phạm vi 10 chứ bây
giờ vừa vào lớp 1 cho cộng trừ trong
phạm vi 1000 làm sao các bạn hiểu được
đúng
rồi ngày xưa ấy với cái h ngày xưa mình
học ấy đây toán mình rất là thích nó rất
là khó hiểu trong cái thói toán trong
machine thì mình đánh giá đây là th toán
nó khó hiểu nhất nhưng nó lại rất là thú
vị nó rất là thú vị tại vì nó có những
đặc đặc điểm là nó linh động về số chiều
nó không chỉ hoạt động trong cái không
gian gốc ban đầu mà nó còn có thể nó tạo
ra cái chiều mới. Đấy. Thế nhưng cũng vì
cái việc mà tạo ra cái chiều mới này nên
cái thời gian này nó có cái tính giải
thích nó rất là khó. Nó cái tính giải
tính giải thích nó rất là thấp. Tại vì
sao? Tại vì bây giờ ví dụ như này, ví dụ
là ở trong trường hợp này đúng không? X1
là bằng mức lương, x2 là bằng số tuổi
đi, x3 mà bằng x1 bình cộng với x2 mũ 3
đi thì làm sao chúng ta có thể giải
thích x3 dưới dạng ngôn ngữ của con
người được? Đúng không? Lúc này khi mà
chúng ta phải thích là vì sao mô hình nó
lại dự đoán như này, vì sao mô hình lại
dự đoán thế kia, các bạn sẽ khó giải
thích. Tại vì bây giờ nó phân chia nó
đâu có chỉ dựa vào cái rượu gốc đâu. Nó
còn tạo ra những cái chiều mới nữa mà
những chiều mới này chúng ta đâu thể
thích bằng ngôn ngữ của con người được
đúng không?
Rồi đấy là về support machine mấy giờ
nhỉ?
Nghỉ giá 5 phút các bạn nhá. Nghỉ ra 5
phút nhá. Chứ vẫn còn chưa hết đâu nhá.
Khi nó tạo chiều mới thì về tính bảo đ
toàn thông tin.
Bảo toàn thông tin tức tức là như nào
nhỉ? Nhưng cái chiều cũ vẫn được giữ
nguyên mà chiều cũ thì vẫn như thế. Nó
chỉ tạo ra chiều mới thôi. Giá trị của
chiều cũ như nào nó vẫn y chang như vậy
mà nó có mất cái gì đâu.
5 phút nhá.
Chắc em phải cho anh cái tài liệu đấy
thôi. Tại vì có thể là nó không phải áp
dụng trong support vector machine đâu.
Tại vì là cái chiều cũ nó có bị làm sao
đâu. X1, X2 nó vẫn còn nguyên mà. Tôi
chỉ cắm theo những cái chiều mới x3, x4,
x5 thôi. Chiều cũ vẫn còn nguyên không
mất cái gì cả.
[khịt mũi]
Bạn nào các bạn thắc mắc gì thì các bạn
cứ hỏi nhá. Mình cũng có chiếc máy ha.
Ở đây là mình đã lược bỏ bớt cho bạn
những cái phần khó rồi. Ngày xưa lúc hồi
mình học hồi mình học trình v mình học
cái khóa cái cái cái cost machining ở ở
Munic ấy. Tại vì là tại cũng không so
sánh được. Tại vì cái chương trình của
mình là chương trình học thuật, chương
trình dài 2 năm nó sẽ khác. Còn đây là
khóa học ngắn hạn. Mình đã bỏ những cái
thứ khó khăn rồi, những cái thứ lằng
nhằng lên toán rồi, những cái thứ khó
nhất là mình đã bỏ hết đi rồi.
[khịt mũi]
Có cái gì các bạn thấy chưa chưa chưa
chưa chưa chưa hiểu, các bạn cứ hỏi
thoải mái nhá. Không phải là các bạn hỏi
hai ba lần rồi các bạn thấy hỏi nhiều
quá các bạn không hỏi đâu nhá. Cứ hỏi
thoải mái được chưa?
Sau cái này cũng cần
đến lúc mà thực hành thì mọi người sẽ sẽ
gọi là
nắm được nhiều vấn đề hơn và và từ đó có
nhiều feedback hơn Việt ạ.
>> Dạ vâng. Ok vấn đề thật ra nếu thực hành
nó sẽ gần như sẽ không có thêm cái gì
mới. Tại vì sao thực hành là tự viện nó
đóng gói hết rồi. Thực hành là thật ra
tất cả những cái chúng ta học ấy nó chỉ
một dòng một dòng một dòng cứ một dòng
và ra thư viện thôi. Thế là thời gian
thực hành nó sẽ không có vỡ ra cái gì
mới đâu. Tại vì là tư nó nó đóng gói hết
mà đóng gói hết ở bên trong.
Anh ơi, cái chỗ mà bổ sung thêm chiều
mới của cái thuật toán vecơ này thì là
khi mà nó tạo ra chiều mới thì nó đang
cố tạo ra thêm các cái tọa độ trên cái
chiều mới để sao cho mà các cái điểm dữ
liệu đấy nó tạo ra được một cái
hyperplane và chia ra được đúng không?
>> Đúng rồi, chính xác. Chính xác.
>> Cái chiều đấy ấ là nó sẽ tự tạo và nó cứ
ẩn xuống dưới là cái mô hình nó đã tự
tạo cho mình để mình có thể [hắng giọng]
chia được chứ nó không liên quan gì đến
dữ liệu của mình em nhỉ?
>> Không, mô hình nó tạo mình nó phải liên
quan đến dữ liệu. Tại vì là cái chiều
mới này nó được tạo ra từ những cái
chiều gốc ban đầu. T ví dụ chiều gốc ban
đầu là x1 x2 ví dụ có một cái ông s1 là
bằng 5 x2 = 6. Cái chiều mới này ví dụ
nó là x1 bình cộng x2 bình chẳng hạn
hoặc là x1 nh x2 chẳng hạn thì nó vẫn là
trên dữ liệu cũ.
>> Tức là nó vẫn là một cái công thức nào
đó liên quan đến để nó tạo nó cố vẽ ra
để nó phân chia cho mình đúng không ạ?
Đúng rồi, đúng rồi. Thế nhưng mà mỗi tôi
là cái chiều mới này tôi sẽ không giải
thích được ý nghĩa dưới dạng ngôn ngữ
của con người. Tại vì là bây giờ mà ờ x1
là diện tích của nhà, x2 là số tầng đúng
không? Thì bây giờ x1 nh x2 mình biết
giải tích nó như thế nào bây giờ? Hoặc
là x1 bình cộng x2 bình hoặc là x1 căn
bậc hai của x1 cộng với căn bậc hai của
x2 luô. Tôi sẽ tôi chỉ là tôi không giải
thích được ý nghĩa của những chiều mới
thôi. Thế nhưng mà chiều mới này sẽ được
tạo ra từ những cái chiều cũ.
>> Vâng. Vâng. Em hiểu rồi. Em cảm ơn anh.
>> Ừ.
Và thông thường các cái chiêu mới này nó
sẽ không phải là một cái tổ hợp tuyến
tính của chiều cũ. Tại vì nếu là nó là
kiểu là ax1 cộng bx2 ấy thì nó sẽ chả
thấy cái vấn đề gì. Tại vì là
tuyến tính thì nó đâu có tạo ra thông
tin gì mới đâu. Đúng không? Tuyến tính
thì nó vẫn là một cái tổ hợp của những
nó là tổ hợp tuyến tính của những cái
cũ. Thì cái chiều mới này thường nó sẽ
là một là nó là những cái hàm lũy thừa
mũ n mũ m hoặc là nó là hàm logarit hoặc
là hàm e. Kiểu như vậy
>> theo anh em hiểu thì nó để những cái hàm
đấy để nó vặn xoắn cái không gian để
>> Đúng rồi. Chính xác chính xác để nó có
cái
>> đúng là như thế để cái hyperplane nó có
thể chui qua giữa dữ liệu.
>> Đúng rồi. Nhưng cái chiều mấy nó nên
những cái chiều máy nó sẽ chiều nó rất
là phức tạp. Tại vì nếu nó nếu nó đơn
giản thì những cái ông chiều cũ nó đã
làm được rồi đúng không? Nó sẽ chiều
phức tạp bình phương mũ 3 mũ n hoặc là e
mũ.
xíu nếu đi làm mẫu mình phải tự
à nếu mình đi làm công ty chưa có sẵn dữ
liệu mẫu mình phải tự thu thập hay là
mình phải yêu cầu công ty tự thu thập
tùy mình tùy mình nếu là mình sẽ yêu cầu
công ty thu thập tại vì mình sức đâu ra
mình làm đúng không mình sẽ yêu cầu xếp
là em cần dữ liệu xếp cho em không có
thì b thì coi như cái việc thu dữ liệu
nó là một cái tas của mình đ không thì
mình sẽ thành ra mình làm cái đấy đúng
không mình linh động mà linh động mà mỗi
công ty nó sẽ khác nhau được chưa còn
công ty nó có như cơ sở dữ liệu rồi các
bạn chỉ truy cập vào các bạn lấy thôi.
Có công ty nó chả có thì các bạn phải đi
thu thập nhá.
[khịt mũi]
Rồi
tiếp các bạn nhá. Tiếp nhá. Rồi vừa rồi
chúng ta nói về nói về
support factor machine. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nói thêm về một
cái th toán nữa. Toán này nó rất là dễ
thôi. T này thì rất là dễ. Support thì
nó khó còn rất là dễ. Đó là cái này nó
gọi là newable. Được chưa? K newestable
tức là
K.
T này cực kỳ đơn giản luôn. Bây giờ cái
ý tưởng của tôi là gì? Đúng không? Vẫn
đúng không? Mình mô phỏng ở trong không
gian hai chiều nhưng các bạn hiểu trong
thực tế là nó dùng trong không gian mấy
chiều thì cũng được. Được chưa? Thế thì
ý tưởng của cây nest table là gì? Cable
tôi dựa trên cái việc là
tôi dựa trên cái việc là bây giờ giả sử
vẫn là bài toán phân loại đi, bài toán
binary classification đi. Được không?
Tôi có hai class. Một class là class
hình tròn, một class là class hình sao.
Được chưa? Bây giờ tôi có một cái simple
mới. Tôi muốn xem xem là cái sle mới này
nó sẽ thuộc vào class nào, đúng không?
Thì tôi có một cách rất là dễ là gì? Là
tôi sẽ xem là cái ông mới này nó gần với
những cái ông nào nhất. Tôi sẽ xem là đa
số những cái ông gần nhất đấy nó thuộc
về class gì. Được chưa? Ví dụ ở đây tôi
tìm xem là trong ba ông gần nhất thì đa
số chúng thuộc về class gì? Tôi sẽ gán
luôn cho cái class đấy. Đúng không? Ví
dụ ở đây trong ba cái điểm gắn nhất như
thế này, tôi có hai điểm thuộc class
hình troll, một điểm thuộc class hình
sao thì tôi sẽ gán cho cái ông mới này
là thuộc về thuộc về class hình tròn
đúng không? Đấy là cái ý tưởng của cây
nebel. Được chưa? Thuận này cái làm rất
là đơn giản. Đầu tiên các bạn phải chọn
một cái số ká đầu tiên là chúng ta phải
chọn một cái số k. không có một quy tắc
nào chọn số k cả nhưng thông thường
người ta sẽ chọn số k này thứ nhất
thường người ta sẽ chọn là số lẻ và thứ
hai người ta sẽ chọn số k này không lớn
quá và không bé quá không thông thường
người ta hãy chọn là 3 5 hoặc là 7 thông
thường là như vậy vì sao người ta lại
chọn số lẻ tại vì cái bài toán phổ biến
là cái bài toán binary classification
bài toán phân loại nhị phân ấy là các
bạn chỉ có hai class thôi. Và với binary
classification ấy thì thì nếu mà các bạn
số can số chẵn thì có khả năng là gì?
thì nó bị huề nó bị hòa nhau đúng không?
Ví dụ là k = 4 thì sẽ có ví dụ là bốn
ông thần nhất lại có hai ông thuộc class
này, hai ông thuộc class kia đúng không?
Thì nó sẽ
thì nó sẽ bị hòa nhau đúng không? Thế
nên người ta thường người ta hay chọn số
k là số lẻ. Tất nhiên số k là số k số k
mà số lẻ ấy thì nó chỉ đảm bảo là cái
trường hợp binary là không bị huề thôi.
Còn trường hợp mà nó có nhiều hơn ví dụ
các bạn k bằng k = 5 nhưng mà các bạn
lại có ba class đi các bạn có ba class
là a b c chẳng hạn đúng không? Bây giờ
giả sử k = 5 thì bây giờ có thể có cách
khả năng là gì? là trong năm cái điểm
gần gần nhất với cái điểm mới này thì có
hai điểm thuộc class A, hai điểm thuộc
class B và một điểm thuộc class C đúng
không? Nó vẫn bị hòa đúng không? Trong
trường hợp nó bị hòa nhau như vậy thì
tôi làm nào để tôi xử lý các bạn. Trường
hợp mà có hai class nó cùng có cùng số
lượng nhiều Cle thì tôi làm nào để tôi
phá cái thế hòa đấy bây giờ?
Làm thế nào bây giờ?
>> Tính trung bình ạ. Hay lấy thêm một
class? À lấy thêm một điểm nữa.
>> Lấy lấy trung bình. Đúng rồi. Hoặc là
lấy thứ lấy trung bình hoặc là tôi lấy
thêm một cái điểm nữa đúng không? K th
tăng lên că b=ng 6 đi. Tôi xem cái điểm
thứ nhất này nó gần ông nào hơn đúng
không? Cách để tôi có thể phá cái thế
hòa này. Đúng chưa?
Thế cái làm rất là đơn giản đúng không?
Đầu tiên các bạn phải xác định một cái
số k. Số k là phải fix từ đầu cố định
chư k = 3 chẳng hạn. Do tôi có cái c1
mới tôi xem là c1 này nó gần với 3 C1 đ
nhất. Tôi xem là đa số chúng là thuộc về
class gì. Thế thôi. Rất là đơn giản.
Rồi cái thờ toán này ấ nó rất là đ đơn
giản và nó có những cái điểm thú vị. Nó
có cái điểm nó chả giống ai cả. Nó không
có cái điểm nó chả giống ai cả. Các bạn
nhìn nhá. Cái điểm không không giống ảnh
của nó là liên quan đến cái quá trình
huấn luyện. Các bạn cho mình hỏi nhá.
Quay lại với tất cả nh những cái thuật
toán chúng ta tìm hiểu từ đầu đến giờ
nhá.
Ví dụ là với
ví dụ là với linear
regression đi. Được chưa? Ví dụ như là
với linear regression đi các bạn chưa?
Công thức tổng quát là y bằ w1x1 cộng
w2x2 cộng wx3 vân cộng wpxp c w0. Được
chưa? Công thức tổng quát như vậy. Được
chưa? Thế các bạn cho mình hỏi này, bây
giờ giả sử sau khi mà mình đã
huấn luyện xong mô hình rồi đúng không?
Mình đã tức là mình có một cái bộ dữ
liệu đúng không? Cái bộ rượu là những
cái điểm màu vàng này đúng không? Đây là
cái bộ rượu của mình đúng không? Sau khi
mình có cái bộ rượu này rồi mình đã huấn
luyện cái bộ rượu này rồi đúng không?
Mình thì ra được công thức của cái đường
thẳng này rồi hoặc là công thức của cái
trong trường hợp các bạn có nhiều hơn
cái công thức là y = w1 w2 nó bằng cái
gì rồi đúng không? Thì bây giờ sau khi
các bạn đã huấn luyện xong rồi, bây giờ
mà mình muốn đem mô hình đi triển khai
thì cái thứ mà mình phải lưu chữ lại nó
là cái gì? Bây giờ tôi có cái mô hình
này, tôi có cái mô hình rồi, tôi có công
thức của y W1, XX1, W2,22 rồi. Tôi có cụ
thể W1 W2 là cái gì rồi. Bây giờ tôi
muốn đem cái mô hình này đi triển khai
trong thực tế để nó dự đoán với những
cái sle mới. Thế thì bây giờ khi tôi
muốn đem mô hình đi triển khai như vậy
thì cái mà tôi cần phải lưu trữ lại là
cái gì? Cái mà tôi cần phải đem đi triển
khai, cái mà tôi cần dùng là cái gì?
Muốn đem mô hình triển khai các bạn phải
lưu chữ cái gì? À w đúng rồi. Cái W đúng
rồi. Chính là cái công thức đúng không?
Cái thứ mà các bạn mất công các bạn huấn
luyện chính là W1, W2, W3 đúng không?
W1, W2, W3 vân vân. WP này chính là cái
thành quả các bạn có được sau khi các
bạn huấn luyện mô hình đúng không? Và
các bạn phải đem nó đi triển khai chứ
đúng không? Bây giờ có một cái sle mới
tôi thay vào W1, X1, W22 là xong đúng
không? C mới nó sẽ có X1, X2, X3, XP.
thay vào công thức này là xong. Được
chưa? Thì các bạn cho mình hỏi này, khi
mà các bạn đã đem mô hình đi triển khai
rồi thì lúc này vai trò của các cái
simple của các bạn trong bộ chuyên này
này nó là cái gì? Khi một khi tôi đã đem
mô hình đi triển khai rồi thì lúc này
vai trò của các cái c này nó là gì?
và trỏ qua cái điểm màu màu vàng này
này.
Khi tôi đã đem mô hình đi triển khai rồi
thì vai trò của những cái m này là gì?
Là gì?
Khi mà tôi đã đem mô hình đi triển khai
trong th trong thư tế rồi thì lúc này
vai trò của các cái datap các cái simple
cái điểm màu vàng này là gì?
Không phải.
Nhắc lại câu hỏi nhá. Khi mà tôi đã đem
mô hình đi triển khai rồi thì bây giờ
vai trò hay là tác dụng của những cái
dat point cái sy này là gì? Ông này tác
dụng nó là gì?
Không phải test à?
>> Không phải test. Làm sao dùng bộ chuyên
để đem đi test được rồi.
Bộ chuyên làm sao đem đi test được? Lúc
này vai trò của nó là gì? Khi mà tôi đã
đem đi ch này không phải cái nữ nào đâu.
>> Nó có thể là nearest neighbor
định cái m không không phải
một khi mà chúng ta đã đem mô hình đi
triển khai rồi thì lúc này các cái này
vai trò của nó là
nó chẳng có vai trò gì cả đúng không?
Hoàn toàn vô dụng đúng không? Đến lúc
này rồi, đến lúc lúc các bạn ngồi vào
phòng thi rồi thì sách vở các bạn đã
từng học làm gì có ý nghĩa gì nữa đâu.
Đúng không? Một khi các bạn đã ngồi vào
phòng thi rồi thì sách vở các bạn đã
từng học nó chả có ý nghĩa gì nữa cả
đúng không? Lúc các bạn đã chỉ mô hình
rồi thì những databon này hoàn toàn nó
chẳng còn tác dụng gì nữa. Chúng ta có
thể vứt hết nó đi. Được chưa? Và các bạn
chú ý này, các bạn chú ý này nhá. Ví dụ
đi, cùng là cái mô hình để tôi tôi cùng
là bài toán, tôi muốn dựa vào kinh
nghiệm để tôi dự đoán lương. Được chưa?
Tôi muốn dựa vào kinh nghiệm để tôi dự
đoán lương.
Ờ
nếu tôi có 100,
tôi sẽ huấn luyện mô hình rất là nhanh,
đúng không? Tôi có 1 triệu sample, tôi
huấn luyện mô hình nó sẽ lâu. Được chưa?
Thế nhưng mà dù là 100 sample hay là 1
triệu sample ấy nó chỉ khác nhau về cái
thời gian huấn luyện thôi. Còn thời gian
đi triển khai là như nhau đúng không?
Cái ông học trăm ông đấy luyện 1000 bộ
đề,
ông lười ông đấy chỉ luyện có 10 bộ đề
thôi. Thời gian học của hai ông là khác
nhau. Nhưng một khi đã ngồi vào phòng
thi rồi thì hai ông đều có 90 phút. Có
đúng không? Thì đây nó cũng như vậy.
Cùng là cái bài toán dựa vào kinh nghiệm
để giới mức lương. Được chưa? Các bạn có
100 sample hay các bạn có 1 tỷ sample nó
chỉ khác nhau cái thời gian huấn luyện
thôi. Còn thời gian khi triển khai là y
hiệt nhau chả khác gì nhau cả. Được
chưa? Đấy là với linear reaction. Tương
tự với polynomial nó cũng thế. Tương tự
với logistic reaction nó cũng thế. Tương
tự với knife bs nó cũng thế. Tương tự
với decision tre random forest cũng thế.
Tương tự với sub machine nó cũng thế.
Được chưa? Các bạn có nhiều hay có ít
sample nó chỉ khác nhau là cái thời gian
huấn luyện thôi. Còn thời gian triển
khai là như nhau. Được chưa? Chỉ khai
chả khác gì nhau cả. Được chưa? Thế bây
giờ các bạn nhìn này. Bây giờ với cây n
sta table các bạn nhìn này. Với cây n
sta table các bạn cho mình hỏi với cây
nable này theo các bạn trong quá trình
huấn luyện chúng ta làm cái gì?
Cây n trong quá trình huấn luyện chúng
ta làm cái gì các bạn?
Mô hình này thuật toán này trong đây ch
lện cho được không sle có sẵn cần gì
phải lưu đâu phân loại không không phải
phân loại phân loại là các bạn phân loại
là các bạn phải có sle vào các bạn mới
các bạn phải có cái sle mới các bạn mới
phân loại được chứ đúng không
trong quá trình huấn luyện các bạn chưa
có cái điểm màu vàng đâu các bạn mới chỉ
có những điểm màu các cái điểm
hình tròn với cả hình à hình à hình sao
thôi đúng không trình huấn luyện là các
bạn chỉ có điểm hình tròn với hình sao
thôi các bạn chưa Có những cái điểm hình
vuông này đâu
nào? Tán này trong quá trình huấn luyện
người ta làm cái gì các bạn?
Lấy đâu ra hyperbane rồi. Support v
machine mới có thôi. Cái này lấy lấy đâu
ra rồi. Lấy đâu ra hybl ở đây?
Các bạn nhìn này. Đây là một thuật toán
không có quá trình huấn luyện. Được
chưa? Đây là một thuật toán không có quá
trình huấn luyện.
Nó có cái gì đâu. Khi các bạn chỉ có
những cái điểm hình ừ hình tròn với cả
hình sao có cái gì mà huấn luyện đâu
đúng không? Hoàn toàn chẳng có gì để
huấn luyện cả. Đây là thuật toán mà mọi
áp lực tính toán là đưa hết vào quá
trình triển khai. Tức là gì? Khi mà tôi
có những cái sle mới vào rồi, lúc này
tôi bắt đầu tôi sẽ đo đảo khoảng cách từ
cái sle mới này đến những cái sle có sẵn
trong bộ dữ liệu của tôi. Được chưa? Vì
đây là thuật toán không có quá trình
huấn luyện. Thế nên thời gian triển khai
ấy nó sẽ phụ thuộc vào kích thước của bộ
rượu các bạn. Cái bộ truy ninh các bạn
có nhiều sample nó chạy nó sẽ nhanh. Cái
bộ xing nó có ít à xin lỗi có ít sample
chạy nó sẽ nhanh, có nhiều sample chạy
nó sẽ lâu đúng không? Nó khác với những
thời toán từ nãy đến giờ linear hay là
logistic ấy đúng không? Nhiều hay ít sle
ấy nó sẽ chỉ ảnh hưởng đến cái thời gian
trên thôi. Còn thời gian triển khai là
như nhau. Còn ông này thì khác. Ông này
là hoàn toàn không có quá trình huấn
luyện đúng không?
Các bạn có 100 sample thì khi các bạn có
một cái sle mới các bạn tính hoách nó sẽ
nhanh. Còn các bạn có 1 tỷ sample thì
khi các bạn có sle mới ngách nó sẽ lâu.
Được chưa? Thế nên thậ toán này nó có
một cái nhược điểm gì là khó mở rộng.
Khó mở rộng. Thông thường thông thường
người ta chỉ dùng thậ toán này khi mà
khi mà số lượng sample của bộ trê nó ít
thôi. Còn nếu nhiều nó không dùng tại vì
nhiều nó lâu đúng không? Ví dụ là khoảng
vài nghìn hoặc là vài trăm vài vài nghìn
hoặc vài chục nghìn thì người ta ok đúng
không? Cứ có mỗi một cái điểm mới các
bạn lại phải ngồi tính khoảng cách cái
điểm này đến tất cả những cái điểm trong
bộ dệu của chúng ta được chưa? Nó là một
tá nó đơn giản
theo các bạn tuần đán này tính giải
thích cao hay là thấp các bạn tính giải
thích là gì? Tôi quay ngược lại tôi giải
thích vì sao mình lại dự đoán như vậy.
Tính giải thích của nó cao hay là thấp
tôi muốn quay ngược lại tôi giải thích
là vì sao mô hình lại dự đoán là đây là
thuộc về class tròn hay là class sao?
Tính dịch của nó cao hay là thấp.
Tính giải thích của cái thuật toán này
cao hay thấp cả hả các bạn?
Vì sao lại cao? Vì sao lại cao?
Vì sao lại cao?
Vì sao tính thể giải th lại cao? Tính
giải thích nghĩa gì? Tức là tôi có thể
sau khi mô hình đưa dự đoán tôi có thể
quay ngược lại tôi giải thích là vì sao
mô hình nó lại dự đoán như vậy thì đấy
là tính giải thích.
Đây là một thuật toán có thích giải
thích rất là cao. Tại vì sao? Tại vì rất
cao, rất dễ giải thích. Tại vì sao? Tại
vì bây giờ nếu tôi bảo là ông này thuộc
class hình tròn, tôi giải thích là gì?
Tại vì trong số ba ông gần giống ông này
nhất thì đa số chúng là về hình tròn
đúng không? Vì sao tôi bảo là vì sao tôi
bảo là ông này là người tốt? Tại vì là
mấy cái ông bạn chơi cùng ông này đa số
là người tốt. Tôi bảo ông này là người
tốt. Còn nếu mà tôi bảo này là người xấu
tại vì là đa số đa số mấy ông chơi cùng
này toàn mấy ông mất dậy cả. Đúng không?
Đấy thấy đấy. Rất dễ đúng không? Rất dễ
giải thích. Tại vì sao? Tôi dự đoán
những ông gần nhất đúng không? Tôi dự
đoán ông này thuộc class này. Tại vì là
đa số những ông gần ông này nhất thuộc
về class đó đúng không? Tính giải thích
rất cao nhưng nhược điểm là gì? Là khó
mở rộng. Khó mở rộng phần lớn lý do là
liên quan đến việc là do là nó không có
quá trình huấn luyện. Mọi cái gánh nặng
về tính toán đều đẩy vào quá trình triển
khai. Nên nếu mà có nhiều sample của Bộ
Chu ấy thì triển khai nó sẽ lâu. Được
chưa? Đấy là ý tưởng của cây label
rồi. Ok. Có bạn nào có câu hỏi thì
không?
Có nào có thắc mắc gì không?
>> Thầy thầy nãy thầy nói em nghe không
nhầm là thầy bảo cái này mình không hiểu
là nó tại như nào sao lại dễ giải tích
hình nhỉ? Đúng không nhỉ?
>> Dạ.
>> Ơ như là cách đ mấy thầy nói là cái kỹ
thuật này là mình không hiểu nó chạy như
nào đúng không ạ?
Em nghe nhầm.
Không không cái này mình mình hiểu mà nó
lấy những cái điểm gần nó xét trong kểm
điểm gần nhất đa số chúng thuộc về cái
nào thì là cái đấy thôi thì là nó thuộc
về class này thôi. Ví dụ đây trong trong
số đây trong số ba điểm gần nhất nó đa
số chúng thuộc về class hình tròn thì nó
là thuộc về hình tròn
data. Tất cả những thậ toán chúng ta nói
từ đầu đến giờ
tất cả thuận toán chúng ta nói từ đầu
đến giờ đều là thật toán supervive cả.
Tất cả từ nãy đến giờ từ linear logic
tất cả chúng đều là superv cả. Tất cả
chúng đều superv đúng không? Phải có
label thì mới biết là ông nào là hình
tròn, ông nào là hình tho à ông nào là
hình là hình sao đúng không? Không có
label làm sao biết ông nào thuộc về cái
gì được.
Nếu có nhiều hình vuông vàng thì Toán có
chọn lel
không? Nó chỉ dựa vào các cái tring data
thôi. Nhiều hình vuông vàng thì chia tức
là các bạn có nhiều bài test thôi. Nhiều
bài test thì tôi chỉ đúng không? Tôi tôi
làm bài kiểm tra đô tôi có 10 câu kiểm
tra tôi làm từng câu tôi dựa vào kiến
thức tôi học từ trước chứ đâu phải tôi
tôi tôi tôi tôi dựa vào cái kiến thức
tôi vừa mới làm cái bài đấy đâu đúng
không 10 cái hình vuông thì cũng làm độc
lập với nhau thôi ông này không biết
liên quan gìến đến ông kia cả được chưa
nable được chưa
một cái điểm nó không hay lắm của cái
nable đó là do là cái cái khánh nặng là
đưa hết về quá trình influence thông
thường các bạn tưởng tượng nhá quá trình
training giống như kiểu các bạn phát
triển sản phẩm ấy đúng không? Thông
thường cái gì khó là chúng ta phải làm
để lúc mà khách hàng họ trải nghiệm ấy
thì nó dùng nó dễ đúng không? Các cái
thuật toán khác ví dụ chuyên lâu là tôi
tôi chịu nhưng mà để làm sao để khi tôi
triển khai tôi khách hàng họ sử dụng nó
dễ đúng không? Đây lại ngược lại thì tôi
chả làm cái gì cả. Khách hàng dùng thì
khách hàng tự làm. Được chưa?
Nếu vậy có trường hợp nào? Chuyện chuyện
bình thường dữ liệu phân bố không đều là
chuyện bình thường. Nó đều thì mới là lạ
còn nó không đều là chuyện bình thường.
không điều chuyện rất bình thường.
Ống rượu thực tế nó sẽ xấu, nó sẽ không
đẹp đâu. Nó sẽ không chịu là chỗ nào
cũng có đủ data đâu. Chỗ chiều có có
những chỗ ít.
Ờ có một cái điểm như này.
Nếu vậy cró thể trả sai class cho mật độ
không? Cuyện bình thường. Tất cả các các
thuật toán này đúng không? Chúng nó đều
có khả năng sai số. Nó cũng như con
người thôi. Con người làm sao lúc nào
cũng đúng được đúng không? Mô hình nó
cũng như vậy đúng không? Mô hình nó cũng
không phải là tiên đúng không? Tất cả
những tự toán chúng ta đã học và chúng
ta sẽ học cái việc mà nó dự đoán sai là
chuyện hết sức bình thường đúng không?
Con người cũng có thể sai thì máy cũng
có thể sai đúng không? Chuyện hoàn toàn
bình thường. Được chưa?
Tất nhiên chúng ta huấn luyện chúng ta
muốn mô hình nó càng chính xác thì càng
tốt. Thế nhưng mà nếu nó sai thì cũng
phải chịu thôi. Đúng không?
Rồi có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Nào có ai có th m gì không?
>> Thế cái k này thay đổi được đúng rồi.
Bạn hỏi gì nhỉ?
>> Cái c số k
này là có thể thay đổi đúng không ạ? K
là một hàng số này hay là một số?
>> Số k lúc ban đầu chúng ta sẽ phải chọn
chúng ta phải thiết lập sẵn ví dụ nó là
3 là 5 là 7. Thông thường người ta sẽ
không chọn lớn quá hoặc là ít hoặc là bé
quá. Tại vì là lớn quá hay là bé quá thì
các cái đa số nó đều có lợi cả. người ta
cuống người ta chọn cái số nó không to
quá không bé quá để cái class thiểu số
nó vẫn còn cơ hội
thường là 3 hoặc là 5 cái giá trị người
ta hay dùng nhá
rồi có ai có thắc mắc gì nữa không nhớ
nhá tất cả chúng ta học từ đầu đến giờ
đều là supervised learning tức là học
với rượu có nhãn nhá đúng không có nhãn
thì các bạn mới thấy màu nó khác nhau
này đúng không có nhãn thì mình có một
ông một ông tròn một ông sao đúng không
có nhãn thì đúng không có nhãn thì các
bạn mới đây này có nhãn thì các bạn mới
có mới có Cái có cái output đầu ra chứ
đúng không?
Không hả gì nhở? linear sau khi train
linear hoặc là linear reaction sau khi
trang nó có cái mô hình rồi là đường
thẳng hoặc là mặt phẳng gần các điểm
trên nhất nên chỉ cần mang cái kết quả
đó chạy thực tế mà không cần dựa trên
nữa. Còn cây stable thì cần phải có dữ
liệu mẫu lúc chạy thực tế để kiểm tra dữ
liệu thực tế thuộc class nào. Đúng rồi,
chính xác.
Mấy ông kia ấy là sau khi huấn luyện
xong tại vì là các cái thuật toán khác
ấy là có quá trình huấn luyện nên huấn
luyện xong là các bạn vứt dữ liệu đi
được đúng không? Giống kiểu các bạn cái
đi học thế thôi đúng không? Các bạn học
lớp 1, lớp 12, lớp các bạn học lớp 10,
lớp 11, lớp 12 rồi, các bạn nạp kiến
thức vào đầu rồi, các bạn có ch huấn
luyện rồi nên lúc đi thi ấy là các bạn
chỉ vác mỗi cái xác vào phòng thi thôi
đúng không? Tại vì là kiến thức nằm
trong đầu mình rồi. Còn cây stable là
gì? Là tôi không học gì cả. Hôm thi tôi
vác cái xác tôi vác sách vở đi thi. Bây
giờ tôi có cái câu nào tôi lại phải dò
sách vở xem là làm như nào đúng không?
Đấy khác biệt nó là như thế đúng không?
Nếu đã học rồi thì lúc đi thi là vác mỗi
cái xác thôi. Còn nếu đã không học thì
đi thi phải vác hết sách vở đi. Đấy
rồi
có nào câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá. Thế nhưng mà cái này
nó không có một cái hay nữa là nếu như
mà trong khi mà thức áp dụng trên thực
tế nhá thì cái dữ liệu mình train nó chỉ
là đúng một cái thời điểm nhất định thôi
nhưng mà sau đấy công ty nó phát triển
lên hay gì đến đó cái cái lượng khách
hàng nó thay đổi cái Google chẳng hạn
thì cái dữ liệu nó thay đổi phải không?
>> Cái dữ liệu thay đổi thì với cái liner
chẳng hạn thì
>> đúng rồi mình phải chuyên theo dữ liệu
thì là cái model nó sẽ thể thay đổi đúng
không? Chính xác. Nếu mà với các cái
thuật toán trước thì mình sẽ phải truyền
lại. Tại vì bây giờ label đổ rồi.
>> Đúng rồi. Chính xác.
>> Trong khi cái thì
>> đúng rồi. Chính xác.
>> Không phải chuyên thì đơn giản hơn tại
vì nó nó đâu có gì trúng cái lợi lợi chỗ
đấy.
>> Đúng rúng rồi. Chính xác. Đấy là một cái
đúng rồi. Tức là nếu mà rượu chúng ta
cái label nó thay đổi liên tục thì chúng
ta đán này nó sẽ tốt hơn. Tại vì tôi
đằng nào tôi cũng không có tôi cũng
không có quá trình huấn luyện đúng
không? Đằng nào cũng không có quá trình
huấn luyện nên là label nó cứ đổi thì nó
cũng chả có vấn đề gì. Đúng rồi. Đấy là
cũng hay.
nhá. Thì nãy giờ chúng ta đều nói với
các cái thuật toán liên quan đến
supervis learning. Bây giờ trong quá
khóa này chúng ta sẽ nói về hai thuật
toán ăn unv, hai thật toán học không có
giám sát, tức là làm việc với rượu không
đánh nhãn. Ngay bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nói
về toán án đầu tiên là cây min casting.
Các bạn chú ý nhá, hai ông này rất dễ bị
nhầm với nhau. Kable và cây min
crasting. Hai ông này rất dễ bị nhầm với
nhau. Lý do là vì sao? Thì lý do nó đều
có chữ K cả. Nó đều có chữ K nó dễ bị
nhầm với nhau. Được chưa? Nên các bạn
nhìn này. King Casting là thực toán học
không ám sát. Tôi sẽ làm việc với dữ
liệu không được đánh nhãn. Được chưa? Ờ
thì cái ý tưởng của tôi là gì? Tôi sẽ
phải phân chia dượa tôi ra làm các cái
cụm khác nhau. Được chưa? Bên phải mình
cho cái màu này để chúng ta phân biệt
các cái cụm thôi chứ còn thực tế nó có
đúng là nó có đúng là ở cái cụm hay
không? Tôi cũng không biết. Tại vì tôi
cũng chả có label. Được chưa? Cái này
thì hôm tới sau khi chúng ta thực hành
xong thì mình sẽ đi sâu vào hơn nhá.
Hiện tại các bạn biết là có hai độc toán
nó đều có chữ K ở đầu. Ở đây là toán rất
dễ bị nhầm với nhau. Người mới học rất
dễ bị nhầm hai cái này. Một ông là
supervive, một ông là unsuper vai. Được
chưa?
Rồi các bạn hôm nay thì vẫn còn nửa
tiếng chúng ta sẽ thực hành một chút
nhá. Cho thực hành một chút. Ờ buổi này
với cả khoảng ba buổi tới là chúng ta
chỉ có tập trung cho thực hành thôi đúng
không? Sau đó sẽ gần như là sẽ so le cứ
một lý tự thực hành đúng không? Hôm nay
là buổi thứ sáu rồi. Chúng ta đã học
cũng tương đối nhiều lý thuyết rồi đúng
không? Chúng ta học cách chúng ta xử lý
tiền sỉ dữ liệu rồi đúng không? Học cách
đánh giá mô hình rồi, học về các kỹ
thuật tuật toán rồi thì bây giờ sẽ cái
lúc chúng ta áp dụng vào. Được chưa? Thế
thì nói về thực hành ấ chúng ta sẽ cần
có một vài những cái thư viện. Cần có
một vài thư viện. Đầu tiên cái thư viện
đầu tiên chúng ta cần đó là đó là đó là
thư viện Pandas.
Pandas là một cái thư viện rất là quan
trọng cho những bạn nào làm data
scientist. Đây là thư viện giúp các bạn
làm việc với dữ liệu có cấu trúc. Tức là
dọ bảng ấy dễ dàng hơn. Các bạn có những
cái file Excel, file CS fe, file Jason,
thậm chí là file HTML các bạn đọc mandat
nó rất là dễ. Được chưa? Thế th cài rất
là dễ. Cài rất là dễ. Các bạn có nhiều
cách cài nhưng mà cách cài dễ nhất là
các bạn cài qua các bạn cài qua cài qua
dòng lệnh. Đ cài qua dòng lệnh mình cho
các bạn thấy nhá. Dòng lệnh thì các bạn
sẽ đây.
Ờ píp cách đâu rồi? Đây mỗi này thôi là
xong. Được chưa? Mình thử cho các bạn
xem nhá. Máy mình thì mình có rồi. Máy
mình thì mình có thư viện này rồi. Mình
mình thử cho các bạn xem nhá. Ví dụ đây
này. Mình mở cái môi trường ra nhá. Nó
có nhiều cách cài lắm. Nó có hai cách
cài. Ví dụ bạn nào các bạn dùng các bạn
dùng VS Code hoặc các bạn dùng P Cam
nhá. Giống như mình. Một là các bạn cài
qua comment này. Đâu pip này. Install
này. Đ. Thông thường cái thự vệ này
thường trong nhiều môi trường nó cài sẵn
rồi. Các bạn muốn biết là mình có hay
không ấy các bạn mở một cái script mới
nhá. Đây mình ghi là
nhá.
Import
trên này nếu import được thì là có rồi,
còn không thì nó chưa có. Thường người
ta hay import như này. Import pandas spd
thế này. Được chưa? Viết tắt giống kiểu
là import 5 snp này. Import 5 SNP này ví
dụ người ta thường hay làm thế này chưa
biết nó gọn. Một là các bạn cài qua
comment như này. Hai là bạn nào không
thích cài qua comment các bạn thích cài
kiểu kéo thả như này. Các bạn thì cái
hình răng cưa đây. Click vào đây được
chưa? Chư cùng bên phải này. Được chưa?
setting này. Cái này là cho P cham nhá.
Còn VS Code giao diện nó khác mình cũng
không rõ lắm nhá. Các bạn chờ một tí
này. Nó sẽ mở một cái bảng này. Được
chưa? Các bạn sẽ chọn là Python này.
Được chưa? Nó có nó có rất nhiều cái tab
này. Python này được chưa? Interpreter
này được chưa? Có hình
đây là mình dùng mình dùng Anaconda nó
có cái vòng màu xanh này mình sẽ bỏ đi.
Còn các bạn là các bạn không dùng thì
các bạn sẽ chỉ có hình con mắt thôi. Con
mắt các bạn nhớ là phải để cái màu sáng
này này nhá. Sáng này ok đúng không? Tối
này không được đúng không? Sáng này.
Được chưa? Và các bạn sẽ click vào đây.
Click dấu cộng này. Click vào đây. Xong
bạn sẽ gõ pandas vào đây.
Panas này. Được chưa?
Đây này. Các bạn nhìn này. Nó sẽ có ở
dưới này. Đấy. Ông nào cũng được. Hai
ông này ông nào cũng được. Đ các bạn
chọn xong các bạn click vào install
packet là xong. Được chưa? Mình thì mình
có rồi mình không cài lại. Các bạn chưa
có các bạn cài. Được chưa? Đây là thư
viện đầu tiên. Đây thư viện giúp các bạn
có thể mở dữ liệu, đọc dữ liệu, ờ thay
đổi modify dữ liệu rất là dễ dàng. Đây
là thư viện đầu tiên.
Thư viện thứ hai là thư viện quốc dân
dành cho dành cho machining. Tên là size
kit learn.
Được chưa? Ceron đây.
Tên thư viện đây. Ceron nhưng mà khi mà
các bạn import ra các bạn sẽ ghi là SK.
Được chưa? Đây là thư viện quốc dân dành
cho machining. Thư viện phổ biến bậc
nhất cho machining. Thư viện này nó giúp
các bạn xây dựng những cái pipeline rất
là dễ dàng, cực kỳ dễ dàng luôn. Những
cái thậc toán mà chúng ta học từ nãy đến
giờ đúng không? Nó lý thuyết rất là là
rất làng nhằng. Nhưng khi các bạn dùng
cái thư viện này các bạn thấy nó đơn
giản mức tận cùng luôn. Các bạn chỉ gọi
nó ra là xong thôi. Rất là dễ. Người ta
không gọi là xây dựng mô hình nữa, th
chỉ gọi là gọi mô hình thôi. Tại vì là
thiết bị viện này nó đóng gói hết rồi.
Được chưa? Thế bây giờ thư viện này dùng
rất là dễ. Thế bây gi đầu tiên muốn dung
bạn phải cài đã. Install này. Được chưa?
Các bạn sẽ một cái câu lệnh như này đây
này.
Đây các bạn chỉ câu lệnh này vẫn còn hơi
giải dòng. Đây mình nhìn ngay nhá. Đây
này chưa này. Pip install này. Và gì ấy
nhở?
Cái lơn đây này. L nhá. này.
Đấy này là xong được chưa? Mình thì mình
có rồi nhưng mà không mình cài lại cũng
được. Đây cài lại đây. Enter một cái
này.
Sao nhỉ?
Đây nhá. Pip cách inst mình có rồi nên
là các bạn cài nó ghi là nó ghi là có
rồi. Được chưa?
đây nhá. Thì bây giờ khi mà các bạn có
rồi các bạn sẽ có thể import được ạ.
Import này đúng không? Nếu các bạn
import được thì là các bạn có được chưa?
Thì đây là hai cái thư viện chúng ta cần
được chưa? Chúng ta có thư viện rồi
chúng ta sẽ cần phải có dữ liệu. Dữ liệu
thì mình up trên thì mình có up lên trên
trên Google Drive của lớp đấy. Thế nhưng
mà đây cho các bạn đỡ phải mất công các
bạn vào lại thì đây mình gửi cho bạn ở
đây luôn nhá. Mình có một cái file tên
là Diabet. Được chưa? Diab đây mình mình
gửi trên Zalo các bạn nhá các bạn. Nào
các bạn mà chưa down trên Google Drive
thì các bạn lấy vào đây cho tiện được
chưa? Cái file này nó như này. Mở ra
trông như thế này được chưa? Đây là một
cái file dữ liệu dạng bảng như thế này.
Được chưa? Dạng bảng như thế này. Các
bạn mở Excel cũng được. Đây mình mở bằng
Excel cho các bạn xem nhá.
Đây nhá. Mở Excel nhá. Đây này.
Đây này. Đấy. Bộ rượu trông như thế này.
Được chưa?
Đây là bộ dữ liệu về bệnh tiểu đường.
nhá. Đây là dữ liệu về bệnh tiểu đường.
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ dùng cái bộ rượu này
để mình hiệp cái mô hình gì đấy. Ví dụ
mình muốn bắt đầu với bài toán
classification. Được chưa? Ví dụ mình
muốn bắt đầu với bài toán classification
tức là gì? Mình có thể mình chọn cái cột
outcome này đi. Outcome 1 là bị tiểu
đường không có nghĩa là chả bị làm sao
cả. Đúng không? Bây giờ mình muốn xây
dựng cái mô hình để dựa vào tám cái cột
kia để mình dự án xem là một người người
ta có bị tiểu đường hay không đúng
không? Mình muốn dựa vào tám cái cột này
để mình dự đoán xem là một người có bị
tiểu đường hay không đúng không? Đấy là
nếu chúng ta muốn chọn bài toán phân
loại. Còn nếu các bạn muốn chọn bài toán
hồi quy thì các bạn sẽ chọn cái cột H
này chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy tức là tôi
sẽ dựa vào tám cái cột kia đ dựa xem là
một người tuổi người ta là bao nhiêu
đúng không? Tùy thuộc các bạn chọn cái
cột gì là cái cột tit thì các bạn sẽ có
bài toán khác nhau. Được chưa? Ví dụ đây
mình muốn làm bài toán phân loại trước
thì tôi chọn cột outcome cưa. Một là
tiểu đường 0 là chả điểm sao làm sao cả.
Nhìn qua một cột hai cột ba cột b cột
năm cột 6 cột 7 cột tám cột chín cột
đúng không? Các bạn có chín cột tức bảo
gồm tám feature với một tarit. Số hàng
các bạn có khoảng 700 bao nhiêu đấy
chưa? 700 768 thì nó bắt đầu từ 1 mà nó
nó bắt đầu từ mấy nhỉ? Bắt đầu từ hai
được chưa 768 hàng.
Đây là mình mở trong Excel. Mình mở
trong Excel đúng không? Còn đây là mình
mở trong mở trong Pam. Thế nhưng mà bây
giờ mình muốn mở trong code, mình muốn
mở bằng code mình làm thế nào? Thì bên
mình sẽ dùng cái thư viện PAS này để
mình mở cái file này ra được chưa? Mình
dùng thư viện Pandas này ở như nào? Mình
sẽ gọi này dataset được chưa? Dataset
này bằng pandas.reit.
Các bạn nhìn này, cái thư viện
ơ
sao lại không gợi ý được nhỉ?
Các bạn nhá. Cái thư viện B này nó có
rất nhiều những cái hàm để đọc. Nó có
thể đọc file Excel bình thường nó phải
gợi ý mình không biết sao lại không gợi
ý này. Nó có thể đọc file Excel, file
CSV, file HTML nó có rất nhiều đúng
không các bạn? Có read CSV nhá. Các bạn
có read Excel nhá. Các bạn có read HPML
nhá. Các bạn có read Jason nhá. Có rất
nhiều hàm read khác nhau, rất nhiều hàm
đọc khác nhau. Được chưa? Nó có rất
nhiều hàm để đọc khác nhau.
Ví dụ đây dùng R CSV đúng tại file mình
là file CSV mà. Được chưa? Mình sẽ
truyền vào cái file là file diabet này.
Được chưa? Đọc như này. Được chưa? Đây
là mình đọc dữ liệu vào. Đọc dữ liệu
vào. Đọc xong mình sẽ in ra. Mình sẽ in
ra print
bet. Được chưa? Prin set này các bạn
nhìn này.
Các bạn nhìn này. Đây là mình in ra.
Đ in ra bộ rượu của mình như này. Được
chưa? Thì tất nhiên là cái bộ rượu mình
ấy nó có rất nhiều hàng và nó cũng có
rất nhiều cột. Thế nên là lúc các bạn in
ra như này ấ các bạn chỉ in được một
phần thôi đúng không? Các bạn chỉ in
được một phần thế này thôi đúng không?
In ra mấy hàng mấy cột thôi đúng không?
Nó chỉ ra năm hàng đầu năm hàng cuối.
Hai cột đầu hai cột cuối. Thế thôi. Được
chưa? Thế thì bây giờ ấy mình mà muốn
xem đầy đủ hơn thì mình làm thế nào? Tất
nhiên là ngoài cách các bạn làm như này
rồi đúng không? Đây cách này thì các bạn
mở dựa vào cái tĩa của Pham. Thế ngoài
ra bây giờ tôi muốn mở trong thần tôi
làm thế nào? Đầu tiên nhá, bây giờ ví dụ
các bạn muốn in ra 10 dòng đầu thì các
bạn sẽ có một cái phương thức là head
này
10 đi. Được chưa? Các m ra 10 dòng đầu
nhá. Nhìn này.
Đấy. 10 dòng đầu đâ này. Được chưa? 10
dòng đầu th này.
Đấy. Được chưa? Thế nhưng mà in ra như
này ấ tôi vẫn bị khuyết các cái cột của
tôi này. Các cột có nhìn được hết đâu.
Nó chấm chấm chấm chấm này. Được chưa?
Thì bây giờ ấy tôi muốn nhìn hết cho ta
làm nào? Thì bây giờ ví dụ với bạn nào
các bạn dùng Pham giống như mình nhá.
Được chưa?
VS Code mình không rõ lắm tại vì mình l
mình cũng mình cũng không dùng bao giờ
nhưng mà mỗi một cái fame code nó đều có
cái mỗi một cái thư mỗi một cái ID nó
đều có một cái công cụ như vậy. Ví dụ
trong B cham nhá. Bạn nào dùng B champ
giố mình các bạn có thể bôi đen nhá. Bôi
đen chỗ này được chưa? Bôi đen một bạn
dùng chuột này bôi đen hoặc các bạn Ctrl
A. Ctrl A này. Bôi đen được chưa? Ctrl A
này. Sau các bạn chỉ chuột vào cái chỗ
màu xanh này. Các bạn click chuột phải
chuột phải nhá. Các bạn chọn execute
selection in Python console nhá. Các bạn
click vào đấy. Được chưa? Các bạn click
vào đấy. Được chưa? Xong khi các bạn
click vào xong, các bạn chờ một tí thì
góc dưới cùng bên phải nó sẽ hiện ra một
cái bảng nhá. Chờ một tí. Bên này
góc dư cung bên phải á nó sẽ hiện ra một
cái bảng như thế này. Được chưa? Hiện ra
một cái bảng này. Thì các bạn sẽ thấy nó
có một cái dòng chữ này. Data frame
7689.
Data frame là cái gì?
Trong Pandas ấy người ta định nghĩa một
cái kiểu dữ liệu là data frame. Data
frame về mặt bản chất nó chỉ là một cái
mảng hai chiều được chưa? Nó là dữ liệu
dọng bảng mảng hai chiều được chưa? Data
frame về mặt bản chất nó là một cái mảng
hai chiều được chưa? Trong Pandas người
ta định gọi nó là data frame. Được chưa?
Data frame các bạn có 768 hàng các bạn
có chín cột được chưa? Bây giờ mình muốn
nhìn nó thì mình sẽ các bạn mình sẽ kích
click vào cái views data frame này nhá.
Views data frame click vào đây. Được
chưa? Các bạn sẽ một cái bảng như này.
Được chưa? Đây là cách mà mình hay dùng
để mình nhìn dữ liệu. Được chưa? Các bạn
có thể dễ các bạn thu ra kéo vào này rất
là dễ này. Không thu ra kéo vào rất là
dễ này. Được chưa? Rất là dễ luôn.
Dễ không? Dễ đúng không? Đấy. Sau đó thì
các bạn nhìn này. Bây giờ mình có
bây giờ mình có các bạn có thể kéo xuống
dưới các bạn nhìn này. Đây xuống dưới
đây đúng không? Kéo lên kéo xuống rất là
dễ dàng. Có một điểm mình rất là thích
khi mình nhìn data fame như này. À mình
mình nhìn dữ liệu này là gì? Nà các bạn
nhìn này, bút một cột nó sẽ có những cái
màu này được chưa? Vẫn bút một cột nhá.
Màu mà càng đen ấy thì giá trị nó càng
bé. Đây này. 0 này giá trị nó càng bé.
Màu nó càng gần màu tím giá trị nó càng
lớn. Thì khi mình nhìn này mình sẽ rất
là nhanh mình nhìn xem là có cái cái giá
trị nào nó đột nó đột biến nó khác khác
lạ hay không. Được chưa? Màu nó đưa ra
theo từng cột các bạn nhá. Màu này đi
theo từng cột. Được chưa? Màu này đi
theo từng cột. Mỗi một cột càng cần đen
thì càng tối. Càng cần màu tím thì nó
càng xin lỗi. Càng cần màu đen thì nó
càng bé. Càng cần màu tím nó càng lớn.
Được chưa? Đấy. Tất nhiên cái màu nó chỉ
áp dụng cho rượu dạng số thôi. Nếu dựa
bạn nó không phải dạng số thì các bạn sẽ
không nhìn được cái màu này. Được chưa?
Nếu rượu nó là tex chẳng hạn các bạn
nhìn thấy toàn một màu đen thôi. Được
chưa? Đây là rượu của chúng ta. Được
chưa? Mở thế này. Mình rất thích mở này.
Phiên bản ngày xưa ấy nó nó phân màu màu
đỏ với màu xanh. Màu xanh là giá trị bé,
màu đỏ giá trị lớn nhưng mà bây giờ nó
thành màu tím và màu đen rồi.
Rồi được chưa? Rồi đến đây có bạn nào
gặp chung chặc gì không?
Đến đây có bạn nào gặp chục chặc gì
không?
>> Ừ, dùng VS code cũng được. VS code nó sẽ
đa di năng hơn. Nó sẽ dùng được nhiều
framework à nó dùng được nhiều ngôn ngữ
lập trình hơn. Còn Phan nó chỉ dùng mỗi
Python thôi. Được chứ? À các bạn nhá nó
một cái nữa này nhá. Thông thường ấy,
thông thường ấy thì khi mà lập trình ấy
mọi người thường có rất nhiều bạn thường
hay có cái xu hướng là các bạn hay dùng
Jupiter Notebook
bạn hay có xu hướng là dùng
Jupiter Notebook hoặc là Google Collab.
Google Collab là chẳng qua là phiên bản
Jú các bạn dùng được GPU thôi đúng
không? dùng JPU đâ vào đây
mình thì mình mình
chưa cài v
rồi làm sao thông thường ví dụ nhá các
bạn hay dùng notebook đúng không nó sẽ
chống như này này
jupiter notebook chông như này
nhá lại như này đấy thường các bạn sẽ
code theo những cái sale như này để chư
Được chưa? Code cái sale này đông code
các bạn tạo ra nhiều cái sale không? Thì
mình chọn cái hình màu
đây nó kiểu như này được chưa? Ngày xưa
ấy hồi mình mới học AI ở theonic ấy
giảng viên của mình cũng hướng dẫn dùng
Zo Notebook nhưng mà mình ấy trong quá
trình mình dạy lập trình từ trước đến
giờ mình không bao giờ mình dùng cái này
cả. Tại vì sao? Tại vì cái xu notebook
nó có một cái đặc điểm là gì? Nó rất là
phù hợp với những người mới học. Tại vì
sao? Tại vì code nó cứ thành từng sale
từng sừng sale. Các bạn chạy cái các bạn
chạy cái sale trước xong ra kết quả các
bạn chạy cái sale tiếp theo đúng không?
Thì với những người mới học nó rất là
dễ. Thế nhưng mà mình thấy có một cái
hiện tượng này. Cái hiện tượng là gì? Là
khi các bạn dùng quen Jupiter Notebook
rồi các bạn rất khó để các bạn bỏ nó.
Thông thường nếu dùng quen Jupiter
Notebook rồi hoặc là Google Col nó chỉ
là phiên bản có dùng GPU thôi đúng không
các bạn? Rất khó các bạn có thể bỏ nó.
Thế thì những cái notebook này những
những cái những cái script du notebook
này các bạn viết cái chương trình đơn
giản thì ok thì ok không có vấn đề gì
nhưng mà các bạn biết là sau này các bạn
sẽ phải đi làm đúng không? Cái kiểu du
notebook ấy là l là lập trình tuyến tính
code từ trên xuống dưới. Ông nào code
trước chạy trước ông nào code sau chạy
chạy chạy sau. Thế nhưng mà sau này các
bạn đi làm nó sẽ không phải như vậy. So
đi làm người ta sẽ không làm một kiểu
lập trình hướng hướng cấu trúc như vậy
mà nó sẽ lập trình hướng đối tượng. Tức
là gì? code các bạn nó sẽ nằm ở nhiều
script khác nhau và không phải ông nào
viết trước sẽ là ông được thực tị trước.
Thế thì
khi mà các bạn cứ bị quen cái việc là
dùng dương nú như vậy thì nó thấy nó nó
sẽ khiến cho sau này khi mà các bạn ra
môi trường đi làm nó sẽ khiến cho các
bạn mất thời gian để bạn có thể làm quen
với các cái công cụ ID chuyên nghiệp.
Được chưa? Đấy là cái lý do thứ nhất.
Code trong thực tế nó sẽ không chạy
tuyến tính từ trên xuống dưới giống như
kiểu là J notebook là cái thứ nhất. Thứ
hai ấy là cái notebook này ấ các bạn
muốn muốn debox cực kỳ khó. Ví dụ với ID
này các bạn có thể đặt break point các
bạn chạy các bạn các bạn chạy cho debug
rất là dễ rất là dễ các bạn có thể tìm
xem lỗi nó ở đâu đúng không? Từng rất là
dễ nhưng mà các bạn dùng S thì chịu
không đặt không đặt break point được
đúng không? Rất là khó.
Ờ mà suy cho cùng sau này các bạn kiểu
gì cũng phải đi làm sao các bạn cứ ngồi
code cái notebook chơi mãi được đúng
không? Các bạn sẽ phải làm ở những cái
project thực tế là những project lớn
nhiều file, nhiều script trồng chéo với
nhau đúng không? Zo này thì các bạn mà
code ở nhiều file nó rất là khó để các
bạn có thể nhảy, các bạn có thể navigate
giữa chúng đúng không? Thường là các bạn
sẽ code mọi thứ trong cùng một file
nhưng mà trong đấy các bạn sẽ phải code
project nó sẽ có nhiều một thư mục con
rồi có nhiều file con đúng không? Thế
nên là từ trưa đến giờ nếu các bạn nộp
bài cho mình, các bạn nộp bằng Zob thì
mình vẫn chấm thôi. Thế nhưng mà mình
thì mình không bao giờ mình hướng dẫn
các bạn là code trên Zoom notebook là vì
lý do như vậy. Có thể mới ban đầu mới
làm quen thì dùng nó tạo cũng ok. Thế
nhưng mà về lâu về dài theo mình là các
bạn nên dùng một cái ID PAM VS Code hoặc
một cái ID gì đấy thì bây giờ các bạn
thích các bạn dùng anti Gravity cũng
được. Đấy nhưng nên có một cái ID để nếu
có debug thì hoặc là các theo dõi nó
cũng sẽ dễ hơn và các bạn sẽ quen với
cái phong cách lập trình khi đi làm hơn.
Được chưa? Mình không nói nó không tốt
mà tại vì là nó dễ khiến người ta bị
nghiện. Tức là cứ dùng cứ dùng hoài thôi
không đổi. Được chưa?
Thấy nhá.
Rồi đến đây mình đọc dữ liệu vào rồi.
Được chưa? Thế bây giờ sau khi đọc dữ
liệu xong đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ phải
làm một vài những cái a thống kê rồi
chúng ta trực văn hóa dữ liệu đúng
không? Thống kê ấy thì ví dụ trong cái
panas này có một vài những cái hàm cơ
bản ví dụ nhá. Win này được chưa? Data
set này h mình gọi data thôi cho gọi đi.
Data cho gọi thôi. Được chưa? Data nhá.
Chấm info nhá các bạn nhìn nhá. Info này
thôi nhầm info bốn chữ quên mất info
nhìn nhá
các bạn nhìn này. Đây là một bài thông
tin về cái kiểu rượu của chúng ta mình
có những cột này parancy nó là kiểu đây
đúng không? Cái như này được chưa? Nhìn
chung đúng không các bạn? Dựa cái detail
các bạn phải xem cái ý nghĩa của chúng
xem có thực sự là dạng số hay không đúng
không? Đây thực sự nó là dạng số này.
Được chưa? số
rồi
đây là một hàm đúng không? Chúng ta có
một vài cái nữa ví dụ là describe
mình có một cái này nhá. Start này
st tích đây đúng không? Mình sẽ show nó
ra nhá.
Đây nhá. Start này nhá. Này đúng không?
Ngoài tố cái cơ bản này đúng không? Số
lượng phần tử sample này 768 này đúng
không? Min là kỳ vọng này. STD là đồ
lệch chuẩn này đúng không? Min này là
giá trị bé nhất này. Tứ phân vị đây. Giá
trị lớn nhất đây. Được chưa?
Được chưa? Một bài những thống kia cơ
bản được chưa?
Rồi. Info disqu đúng không? Sau các bạn
có thể các bạn vẽ một vài những cái vẽ
một vài những cái vẽ một vài những cái
biểu đồ nhiều biểu đồ. Thì thông thường
ngày xưa như mình ấy là sẽ phải in ra
một vài những cái thống kê rồi vẽ một
vài những cái biểu đồ.
Nhưng bây giờ mình chỉ các bạn một cái
thư viện giúp các bạn có thể in ra các
cái thống kê, in ra các cái biểu đồ và
gói chúng lại vào một cái report rất là
dễ dùng. Các bạn chỉ chạy một lần thôi.
Được chưa? Cái thư viện này tên nó là
data profiling nhá.
À đâu rồi?
Đây sẽ tiếng Việt đấy nhỉ?
Đây nhá. Thư viện này tên là Data
Profiling. Nhưng mà có một cái điểm này,
cái thư viện này
là nó phải dùng với nó phải dùng với
Python phiên bản dưới 3.10 à
dưới 3.10
11 thì phải. Chờ một tí nhá. Mình xem
lại hướng dẫn nó nào. Installation này.
Đây đây
nó yêu cầu là Python phải à
đâu nó bay đi đâu rồi ấ nhở? Tức là nếu
mình nhấm nó phải dưới 3.11
còn trên 3.11 thì hình như là ví dụ 3.14
3.13 là không dùng được. 3.12 mình không
rõ lắm. Mình check thử nhá. Mình check
cái phản của mình này nhá.
Pon
này của mình là 311 đúng không? Như là
311 trở về xuống thì ok, còn trên 311 là
không được thì phải. Thế bây giờ mình sẽ
phải cài cái thi viện này. Được chưa?
Cài đây
trừ U có hay không cũng được. Tại vì đây
trừ U có nghĩa là user đấy đúng không?
Có hay không cũng được nhá. Mình cài thử
nhá.
Các bạn mà cài không được ấ có nghĩa là
phiên bản Pon của các bạn nó mới quá.
Bây giờ đến ba bây giờ nó ra đến 3.14
rồi. Phiên bản các bạn mà mới trên 3.11
thì khả năng cao là các bạn không cài
được. Như mình cài thử nhá.
Mình thì có rồi nên là cài lại thì nó
cũng báo là đây này. Requirement satisfy
các thứ này đúng không? Có sẵn rồi. Đây
này. Đấy cài xong rồi này. Được chưa?
Thì các bạn nhìn nhá. Cái thư viện này
giúp các bạn tạo ra những cái report như
này này. Nó giúp các bạn tạo ra những
cái report trông như này này. Đây này.
Rất là đẹp. Được chưa? Rất là đẹp. Thế
thế bây giờ các bạn cài đi. Các bạn cài
đi. Các bạn cài xong nhá. Các bạn cài
xong rồi bên mình sẽ chỉ các bạn cách để
các bạn có thể làm sao các bạn cài các
bạn tạo ra những cái report rất là rất
là dễ nhìn nhá. Bây giờ ở đây là code
của mình đây. Được chưa? Bây giờ mình sẽ
không ngồi in thủ công này nữa. Bây giờ
mình sẽ có một cái dòng import là à form
e data cái các bạn chú ý nhá. Lúc cài
thì là cái dấu trừ này nhưng mà cái lúc
import ấy là các bạn phải dùng cái dấu ở
dưới này
đâ như này.
Import cái gì nhỉ? Profile report nhá.
Được chưa? Form e data undersore một cái
profiling import profile report. Được
chưa? Thế sau đó ở dưới mình mình sẽ tạo
ra một cái report từ cái data này được
chưa? Tạo dong k report này thì gọi là
profile. Profile bằng profile report
được chưa? Mình bọc cái data của mình
vào được chưa? Và mình sẽ cho nó cái nó
một cái title. Cái report này mình sẽ có
một cái title.
Ví dụ mình gọi là debity report.
Ví dụ như vậy. Được chưa? Ví dụ như vậy
cái title là cái tên của cái report
thôi. Được chưa? Tên có cũng được chả có
cũng chả sao nhá. Cái này là optional có
được chả có cũng chả sao. Được chưa? Đây
bước các bạn tạo report. Sau khi tạo
report xong, các bạn sẽ phải xuất nó ra
một cái file đúng không? Các bạn phải
xuất ra một cái file gì đấy để sau các
bạn có thể mở ra đúng không? Thì cái
định dạng file mà dễ mở nhất,
máy nào cũng mở được, Mac OS cũng mở
được, Linux cũng mở được, Windows cũng
mở được là định là định dạng gì các bạn?
Định dạng gì? File file định dạng gì dễ
mở nhất các bạn?
CSV
cũng tùy thôi. CSV ừ CSV
cũng được. CSV cũng dễ mở nhưng mà nếu
CV các bạn không không lưu chữ hình ảnh
được. Tex không lưu chữ hình ảnh được.
Tôi muốn có những cái
>> HTML.
>> Cái cái gì cơ?
>> HTML đúng rồi. HTML Jason không lưu chữ
ảnh được. CSV Tex với cả Jason không lưu
chữ ảnh được. Mình muốn có cả những cái
hình ảnh cơ đúng không? Thì vậy HTML là
dễ nhất. Được chưa? Các bạn nhìn thấy
một cái dòng này chấm to file này chung
to file này các bạn sẽ lưu nó ra một cái
file gì đấy ví dụ mình gọi là debity
mình gọi như này đi được không các bạn
cho nó đu đuôi gì nó sẽ thành cái file
đấy đuôi Jason nó thành file JSON đuôi
text nó thành text nhưng mà đuôi html
thì nó dễ mở nhá đúng không các bạn mở
máy nào cũng có được chưa mình chạy thử
nhá cái này chỉ chạy một lần thôi tạo
report chạy một lần thô nhìn này
nhá các bạn chờ chút này lần đầu chạy nó
sẽ hơi lâu mà các bạn chỉ chạy một lần
thôi. Nó sẽ tạo ra một cái report từ cái
data của mình nhá. Sau các bạn sẽ mở sau
mình sẽ mở cho các bạn xem xem report nó
có cái nó có cái gì nhá.
Hơi lâu một tí các bạn nhá. Lần đầu chạy
nó sẽ hơi lâu.
Trong lúc chờ bạn nào các bạn muốn hỏi
gì các bạn cứ hỏi nhá.
Ô lỗi n
cái phiên bản bé hơn được chưa?
Nó cần phiên bản 5 bé mình lại có 5 p
lớn này. Cài lại nào. 5 n 5
thế mình cài phiên bản bé thôi.
Xong rồi à. Nhanh thế. Pip install. 5
bằng 2/3.
Các bạn nào mà không bị lỗi như mình thì
chắc là các bạn mở ra rồi đúng không?
Pam nó là cái ID nó không liên quan
Python. Nếu Python của mình phiên bản
mới quá thì có thể sẽ không cài được.
Pam là nó là cái ID. Python nó là ngôn
ngữ lập trình nhá.
thì mình sẽ để mình tạo ra một cái môi
trường mới. Mình tạo ra một cái môi
trường mới. Bạn nào các bạn không các
bạn không không biết cách tạo môi trường
thì sau với các bạn bảo mình sẽ chỉ các
bạn cách các bạn tạo môi trường mới, tạo
môi trường level thấp thôi, tức là
Python thấp thôi thì nó sẽ sẽ chạy được.
Cái này cái cái cái thư viện này người
ta không biết vì sao người ta không cập
nhật cho những cái phí bề bản Python
mới. 3.10 11 trở xuống thì an toàn, 3.12
thì hình như là không cài được
nhá. Bạn nào các bạn không biết cách để
tạo môi trường mới, không biết cách hạ
phiên bản thì các bạn bảo mình sẽ xong
mình sẽ Ok xong rồi. Ôi nhiều lỗi thế
này. Không sao cài được rồi đây này.
Chạy thử lại nhá.
Đây này. Xong rồi. Đây này.
Nhiều lắm các bạn dùng con down là các
bạn
chờ thì đã xong. Thật ra các bạn hỏi
chat VT ra ngay thôi. Đây các bạn chat
VDT là ra ngay thôi. Có cái gì đâu đây
đúng không? Mình chả cần chat nhá. Đúng
không? How to create
a new environment
in Python đúng không? Vãn ra ngay. Đấy
nó hiện ra các bạn ngay đây này. Có hai
cách. Một là các bạn dùng cái có sẵn đây
này. Tạo môi trường mới này. Tên môi
trường đây này. Virtual environment. Hai
là các bạn dùng con. Mình thì hay dùng
con này mà con này thì có thể với các
bạn mới các bạn sẽ hơi lằng nhằng một
tí. Thì các bạn dùng cái ở trên này.
Đấy. Nhưng tạo môi trường mới các bạn sẽ
phải chỉ ra là các bạn dùng nhưng mà
trước đấy các bạn sẽ phải down cái
python thấp hơn bình thường víụ nhá các
bạn. Đây này. Python.org nhá. Các bạn sẽ
phải down cái nó hơi lăng nhằng tí thôi.
Các bạn sẽ phải down cái phiên bản thấp
hơn. Đây này. Đ download này. Nếu mà
không muốn dùng phiên bản này các bạn sẽ
dùng cái phiên bản thấp hơn ở đâu ấy
nhỉ?
Download
đây nhá. Phiên bản mới nhất thì đây. Còn
các bạn có thể dùng cái phiên bản cũ
hơn. Phiên bản cũ hơn nó ở
đâu ấy nhỉ?
Fous Python version
đây
chẳng cũ hơn đây. Đấy down ở đây này các
bạn cài cái phiên bản nào thì lúc các
bạn tạo môi trường mới ra nó đúng phiên
bản đây được chưa quay ở đây nhá. Đ xong
rồi này tạo xong report rồi các bạn nhìn
thấy nó sẽ có một cái file như này một
cái file ghi là
một cái file ghi đây này. Cái file nó
ghi tên là đâu rồi?
Máy mình đơ luôn này.
Đây rồi
các bạn nhá. Đây này. Có file này typ
report này. Mình dùng trình chrome trình
mặc định nó như này. Mở mở ra nhá các
bạn. Nhìn này. Đây này. Report đây này.
Đây nhá. Ừ. Có nhiều cách để tạo môi
trường mới lắm. Nhiều cách lắm. Nhưng
các bạn nhìn ra đây này. Đây cái report
của mình. Mình nói qua một tí nhá. Cái
report này nó có đầy đủ các cái thống kê
và và những cái biểu đồ cơ bản nhá. Đầu
tiên này tên report diy report cái vậy
mình tạo ra này đây này diabet report
này đấy là nó đây này góc chung cù bên
trái này được chưa nhìn qua nhá đây một
vài nhệ thông cơ bản này mình có bao
nhiêu biến được chưa chín biến bao gồm
là tám feature với một tit có bao nhiêu
sample đúng không bao nhiêu bị khuyết
bao nhiêu trùng lặp nhau được chưa
variable đây các bạn nhìn này ở dưới này
mình có từng cột một này petancy nhácy
này các bạn thấy không nó có các cái
thông tin là có bao nhiêu giá trị khác
nhau phần trăm giá trị khác nhau là bao
nhiê bao nhiêu giá trị bị khuyết phần
trăm bị khuyết là bao nhiêu
bao nhiêu giá trị vô hạn phần trộ bao
nhiêu kỳ vọng à min max các thứ này đúng
không đủ các thứ này dưới có có những
cái feature khác nữa các cái các cái
biến khác nữa đúng không và các bạn có
các cái outcome nữa được chưa nếu các
bạn muốn cần trong thiên chi tiết hơn
chi tiết hơn thì các bạn click vào cái
vào cái more detail này được chưa đây là
cái histogram này các bạn ơi đây là cái
histogram đây này histogram đây đúng
không các bạn click về more detail nhá
more detail này nhìn này đây là những
cái thống kê chi tiết hơn đúng không tứ
phân vị đây q1 medan q3 đây đúng Không,
khoảng cách giữa Q3 với Q1 này được
chưa? Standard deviation các thứ này rất
nhiều cái thống kê khác nhau được chưa?
Rất rất nhiều thống kê khác nhau ở đây.
Muốn histogram một là ở trên này, hai là
ở dưới này. Được chưa? Common value
những cái giá trị thường xuất hiện được
chưa? H value là những giá trị lớn nhất
hoặc là bé nhất được chưa?
Tất cả đều có những cái thứ như thế được
mod detail đây. Được chưa? Rất nhiều
thống kê chưa? Các bạn sẽ không phải
ngồi các bạn gõ thủ công nữa. Được chưa?
Sa các bạn mà muốn gắn vào report ấ các
bạn chụp cái này gắn vào report là xong
rất là dễ được chưa? Thế ngoài ra nó c
có một vài những cái thứ nữa liên quan
đến ví dụ đây à ví dụ các bạn nhìn nhá
ví dụ là cái
ví dụ là đây là cái interaction nó giống
kiểu cái scatter magic plot ấy. Tức là
gì? Các bạn sẽ chỉ ra hai cái variable
nó sẽ cho các bạn cái hình trực quân hóa
khi mà tôi chỉ quan tâm đến hai cái var
đấy thôi. Được chưa? Đúng không? Tôi chỉ
quan tâm đến hai ông thôi. Tôi sẽ vẽ ở
đây được chưa? Coation đây. M hệ số
tương quan đây. Dạng màu cũng có này.
Dạng số cũng có này. Được chưa? Nhìn vào
cái nào cũng được. Được chưa? Mixing
value mình không có. Bộ dệ mình hoàn
toàn không có missing value đúng không?
Không có. Được chưa? Tất cả đều 768. Ông
nào mà missing nó sẽ thấp hơn còn đều
768 vào thì không nào bị miss cả. Được
chưa? Một vài sle đầu và một vài sle
cuối. Đấy cái thường ngày xưa của mình
ấy không có cái thư viện này nên là mỗi
lúc mình cần làm thống kê mình phải gọi
một vài hàm ra. Gọi rất nhiều hàm ra.
Nhưng bây giờ có cái report này rồi các
bạn chỉ chạy một lần thôi. Sau khi chạy
xong rồi các bạn à tắt mấy dòng này đi
chưa? Tắt mấy tắt cái dòng này đi. Được
chưa? Bạn nào mà các bạn chưa chưa cài
được là do phiên bản nó cũ hơn ấy thì
mình sẽ gửi cho bạn trên Zalo nhá. Chưa
trước khi các bạn cài được thì mình sẽ
gửi tạm trên Zalo để các bạn nhìn nhá.
Được chưa? Mở cái report ra các bạn mở ở
đâu cũng được. File html thì gần như là
mở ở đâu cũng được cả. Được chưa? Thì
đây cách để các bạn có thể tạo được
report được chưa? Report này nó sẽ bao
gồm cái gì? Nó sẽ bao gồm những cái
thống kê rất là chi tiết và nó bao gồm
cả những cái biểu đồ rất là cơ bản nữa.
Được chưa các bạn? Có có thể các bạn
dùng cái navigator ở trên này, overview
này, variable này, interaction này,
coration này, rất nhiều thứ khác nhau
này. Được chưa? Tư lên trên này.
Rồi ok.
Ngoài cái thư viện này ra nó còn một vài
thư viện khác nữa nhưng mà mình thấy là
cái thư viện này nó gọi là nó nó
có vẻ là ok nhất. Có nhiều thư viện nó
có những cái thống kê rất là rất là chi
tiết nhưng mà nó chi tiết quá mà thường
mình không cần đến cái mức đấy. Đây mình
thấy là tổng hòa được cái sự đơn giản
với cái sự đầy đủ nhá.
Ok. Nó chỉ mỗi cái nhược điểm là nó
không hỗ trợ cái bần bản cao. Không biết
là vì sao lại lại như vậy nhá. Bạn nào
các bạn có trong trong cài các bạn có
thể bảo mình mình sẽ mình hỗ cho các
bạn. Thật ra chat nó hướng dẫn hết các
bạn mà chat hướng dẫn hết mà không các
bạn có thể hỏi mình cũng được nhá.
Đấy thế thôi
nào có câu hỏi gì không
thế nhá. Đấy hai buổi tuần sau là chúng
ta cũng full thực hành được chưa? Hai
buổi tuần sau và cái buổi thứ bảy tuần
sau nữa chúng ta cũng chỉ full thực hành
thôi đúng không? Sau đó sẽ so lẹ cứ một
lý thuyết một thực hành nhá.
Cái phần khó nhất của khóa này là hết
rồi. Phần khó nhất của cái khóa này là
hết rồi. Từ giờ đến cuối khóa là nó chỉ
có dễ hơn thôi nhá.
Ok. Thấy nhá. Tuần sau vẫn bình thường
các bạn nhá.
Mình cũng chả biết nữa. Nó trông có vẻ
là những cái những cái comit mới nhất
thì vẫn đây này. Commit mới nhất mấy hôm
này. Mấy hôm trước vẫn commit bình
thường bạn chả hiểu sao là
chả hiểu sao nó chỉ cài được với Python
cũ thôi. Pyon mới không chạy được.
Rồi hôm sao mình tạo vài cái môi trường
ảo ra một cái môi trường ảo để để một
cái môi trường ảo mình để cái phiên bản
cũ thôi. Cứ nào cần chạy thì mình tạo
report mình chạy nó một lần thôi. Xong
mình tắt nó đi mình code bình thường
thôi. Cái này chỉ chạy một lần thôi. Đ
một khi có cái report này rồi thì khỏi
phải chạy nữa. Report rồi khỏi phải chạy
nữa nhá.
Ok thế các bạn nhá. Rồi chúc các buổi
tối vui vẻ. Tuần mới học tập và làm việc
hiệu quả. Tuần sau chúng ta vẫn học bình
thường các bạn nhá. Nhá.
Ok, cảm ơn mọi người rất là nhiều nha.
Có ai có thắc mắc gì trong cái nội dung
hay là có cách thắc mắc gì trong việc
cài đặt các bạn cứ ới mình nhá. Cài đặt
có cái gì khó hoặc là nội dung có gì bạn
chưa hiểu cứ hỏi mình nhá. Ok. Cảm ơn
mọi người nha. Mọi người rất nhiều nhá.
T sau học tiếp nhá.
M.